How even!
We didn't get to do a countdown!
We didn't get to do it!
You guys are awesome!
What the heck?!
Thank you so much, everybody!
We've already prematurely hit our first...
Well, there's more stretch going on.
I mean, there's more stretch goals and stuff, but we didn't
start yet.
Thank you.
Wow, wow, wow, wow.
Wow.
Oh my gosh.
Really means, it really, really does mean a lot.
So this is for a good cause.
Thank you, you guys.
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
And condense, condense, condense, everyone.
Hello.
We are denser to that, you next to it.
Oh, should we do the thing?
Should we do this?
Should we?
I don't know.
I feel like... Yeah.
I feel like we're having like kind of a formal stream today.
I don't know.
This is a formal thing.
Our call and response is very formal.
It's so formal.
It's so... I don't know.
But you do the formal version.
What's the formal?
What's the...
Oh, would you please do us the honor of being a part of our
story?
We are known as You, yourself.
Oh, perhaps do you mean me?
Yes, yes, yes.
Sounds perfect.
Whoa, guys, we're on 15k now.
What is happening?
Thank you.
Oh, my gosh.
I'm going to wear a stretch doll.
I'm going to cry.
Oh.
Wow.
You guys, you guys.
Oh, my gosh.
Your guys' donations are making making such a difference
even just one thousand dollars um expands the stream for
hope program to reach thousands more online so you know 500
equips one school with the proactive mental health resources
and training as well so you guys are really doing amazing
work so far crazy yeah amazing the goal jumped what happened
the goal yeah wait do we have do we have that stretch goal
oh you can edit it on the page i think yeah yeah yeah what
is this oh wait two times donation match in progress as well
oh wow wow wow wow wow thank you so much rather
Oh my god!
You guys!
I don't even know what to say!
You guys are so generous!
That has not heard of Hope for the Day.
They focus on making a more awareness of mental health
issues and, you know, ending the stigma behind talking about
how you're feeling because, you know, some days it's okay to
not be okay.
And here, you know, we, the three of us, we support you guys
so much and we want you guys to all feel like, You know,
you're always, you're always supported as well.
And, um, yeah, so it's going towards, you know, uh, oh, my
braid just blagged.
Sorry, I was reading.
No, no, no, it's okay.
Yeah, it's going towards so many great things.
$25.
Princeton distributes a hundred mental health resource
cards.
Um, the, you know, a really amazing can save a life.
$200.
a community education workshop that's free for all
participants so they're really doing um amazing amazing work
yeah it's a really really great cause yeah it can be scary
to reach out for help when you need it but they're making it
more accessible and more comfortable for people who need it
um they're educating people about about mental health and
about the different resources that there are they're
educating educators so that they can spread the word as well
and the workshops and and there have been so many so many um
people coming together for this cause lots and lots of
streams have happened over 220 streams so far wow over 2
million people have been reached by these kinds of streams
and now you guys are part of that effort too so thank you
you oh i mean we've already hit a lot of our goals and
incentives but do we want to review them together and talk
about what we have hit already which is crazy yeah what do
you guys want to start with the goals or the incentives uh
the goals let's go with goals yeah let's do goals one second
all right i'm gonna oh wait i'm trying to find a way to have
it not high the girl it might be a little small guy sorry
all righty so for our goals we've hit um
well because of your generosity everybody's help you will
now get we will now have later on in the stream we'll have
an out of characters script reading challenge
It's gonna be great, you guys.
Yes, we all put our noggins together to come up with some
fun stuff.
Oh yeah, oh yeah.
And then you'll also be choosing, we're gonna, like later on
we'll have like a, some, in the, what do you call it, the
community tab, I believe.
We'll have like a post where you guys post your suggestions
on what kind of group art you'd like to to be used i'd like
to be created for a digital wallpaper and you guys can vote
and whoever has like the most likes and everything will be
the chosen concept for said wallpaper for you guys you guys
are so uh so creative and definitely not cursed so i am i'm
excited to see what kinds of things you come up with they're
gonna put us in like burger mascots or something yeah what
I'm scared.
I'm scared, scared, but excited.
Oh, we'll be the new mascots for the J.R.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
Oh, no, wait.
That's horrible.
Wait, guys, who would each of us be out of the new mascots?
Tag yourself.
Wait, hold on.
Wait, I need to look them up again.
I need to look the monkey with the pouch.
There's the big scary bunny.
And then there's like one more.
The one bunny.
The only the cute, the only the square.
is cute like the squirrel yeah I'm gonna be real cute but
kind of basic look I'm gonna be real with you guys I'm not a
fan of the squirrel really I kind of would want one of the
other two I think it's like the worst or the best out of the
three but it's still kind of horrifying I don't know I just
think if they're gonna go for it go for B you know go I
agree yeah go hard King B It's the That's the rabbit right
Yeah Yeah That's called the rabbit Yeah What even What is it
Oh wait It's got a little friend though Like the anxious Oh
yeah This is the cutest story I think So it's like It's like
they take their little friend The mole around Because the
mole hasn't seen The outside world Because he's been in the
ground I didn't know there was a lore Behind that Yeah
there's lore I was translating it a chat the other day so
the the the yeah it's like he takes the mole around to see
the world because the moles only seen inside the ground yeah
so i think that's a cute like story at least for it yeah
wait what was the bunny why is it horrifying the bunny is
apparently jumping into the future like you know like seeing
the future yeah and like apparently the purple gives a
feeling of safety and sort of like is what it said.
No, not that, but...
Guys, we've reached 30k.
30k!
Holy moly!
Thank you!
Let's continue to talk about what that means then.
Yes, yes, yes, yes, sorry.
You guys unlocked.
Then, Setsu does 3D VR chat stream together!
Yay!
And just to clarify, we will be actually...
Exploring some VR chats later today, but this will be a
separate thing, a separate, separate thing that maybe you
guys will see us in...
I don't know, looking a little different.
Whoa!
Yeah!
Thank you!
So much!
Oh my gosh.
Oh my goodness!
Also, of course it's $6,700, of course.
I'm so proud of you.
Don't say of course that is so much of money!
Actually...
Actually, did you know that Hidden Nin...
You remember how the puppets...
At the fund... at the auction sold for 6.7k?
You remember that?
Yes.
They sold to Toby, right?
Well...
Hidden Nin purposeful...
Was going head-in-head with Toby and purposefully stopped
the number at 6.7k.
Oh, my God!
Amazing.
Oh, my God.
Commitment to the bit.
is to be respected.
We'll definitely go through, I want to go through and say
thank you to all your guys' names later, but first, we're
going to talk about the incentives.
What have you guys unlocked?
Okay, almost everything.
Who wants to do this one?
By the way, 6,000 does have a chance.
It does have a chance to be taken back.
But go ahead, Phoebe, go ahead.
Yes, there is a chance.
And I'm relying on you guys.
I beg of you.
I was like, oh, I saw someone in chat earlier be like, oh,
uh, um, Goals?
What about Batu?
This is the Batu.
This is a Batu.
This is the...
But
also, if you...
If we hit 50,000, I'm declaring this now.
If we hit 50,000, we will not do the League of Legends
stream.
Wait, what?
We will not do it.
Wait, so you're saving their...
Wait, so are we saving them from the...
The...
We're saving everyone.
We're saving the world.
We have to replace it with something though, no?
Okay, fine.
50k, we don't do it.
100k, we do it.
We do it.
Oh my god!
Is that better?
What if the manager's skydiving, he's playing League of
Legends while skydiving.
For him, I would just...
I would just not.
I would just...
I would just parry.
Of sadness.
Oh my god.
Well, League of Legends guys, right now we're playing and
I'm very excited.
It's gonna be great guys.
It's gonna be great.
I'm so excited to play with you guys.
Huh?
You're playing?
What?
I've never played it before.
No.
I've never played it before either.
So...
I've been intrigued for a long time.
8,000.
Chad chooses a song for next full cover.
Similarly to the digital wallpaper, how that will be posted
as like a community thing on the Densitik channel.
And you guys will post what kind of cover you want us to do.
And then you'll like the comments that you think sounds
great and vote.
And whichever is the most liked, we will do a cover.
So you guys choose.
You choose.
Yeah.
You guys do choose.
I mean, what?
What are they going to choose?
You guys can start thinking of what silly, cursed things you
want to ask us to cover.
Or maybe something serious.
We'll see.
It can be anything.
Well, not anything.
We have the right to veto, but mostly anything.
Yeah, mostly anything.
We have the right to veto if it's a really, really, really
silly one.
Yeah, if it's two curses.
I'm seeing a couple people saying Enka though.
That'd be so exciting.
That'd be so fun.
Wait, Numa Numa is actually a great shout because there's
three.
of them what language is that in again uh i believe don't
quote me romanian oh that sounds right yeah i've been told
by someone who speaks romanian that i sing that song very
well so i i took that as a compliment next karaoke next
karaoke yeah teach us teach us um at 10 000 we have future
then says a little exe vacation vlog wow this one is crazy
we were like oh we'll make it 10k we'll never go on vacation
what's what is that
well i know we've already like kind of like you know we've
done things where we've gone on a little trip together and
we've posted pictures but we've never like filmed it have we
so i think it could be really sweet to take you guys along
with us yeah We've already talked before about like dream
spots that we'd like to go to on vacation together to see
certain animals and the palace cats.
The palace cats.
Oh, take me there to the palace cat tour.
It's like so many dollars, but yeah, maybe one day.
Thank you for 40k, you guys.
Oh my goodness.
40k!
That's like whatever amounts of...
That's a lot.
Wow, thank you guys.
But yeah, well, I guess we should start planning a vacation
together somewhere.
I don't know.
Oh, that's exciting.
Yeah, so many fun places that we could go.
I vote the dinosaur onsen.
Yeah!
We'll think about it.
What is this?
What is this dinosaur onsen?
It's like dinosaur themed?
It's in Fukui.
Yeah, Fukui, the dinosaur prefecture, yeah.
Yeah, there's so many fossils and stuff.
And a huge, huge museum there.
It'll be so awesome if we go.
Yeah, we're so excited.
Yeah.
And then who wants to say the big one at 12,000, which was
our big goal, but we're already nearly four times the
amount.
Yeah.
Someone just said New Jersey, please.
New Jersey.
I want to go to...
Wait a while I want to go.
I want to go to Texas.
I have Texas Barbecue.
Oh, that'd be so fun.
Texas Barbecue.
Barbecue.
Yeah.
Our big...
Our big goal, which was our original goal.
Yeah.
As you guys will now get a...
...
Free stream 3D YouTube content!
Whoa,
whoa, whoa, whoa.
Yeah, yeah.
So exciting.
Oh, yeah, we've been wanting to do this for a while, haven't
we?
And we thought this would be a perfect time to put it on the
goals and see if we hit it.
Yeah.
So exciting.
So I guess we'll start planning that for you guys.
Yeah.
We're going to work really hard and make it something super
awesome for you guys.
Yes.
Yeah.
So exciting.
It might take a little bit of time, but we got to practice
and everything.
Yes, don't be expecting these like tomorrow, chat.
Like, give us some time.
It will be this year, though.
Probably, right?
We think.
Probably.
Most likely.
Probably?
I'm being...
Probably.
We'll do our very best, too.
Yeah.
There's still three...
Wait, yeah, three months and a half in the year.
That's enough time.
Maybe.
Yeah.
Oh, so exciting.
And then we have the stretch goals Who'd like to go Phoebe?
What's our first stretch goal?
20k, which you guys already hit.
You guys will choose a genre Of one of our future original
songs We don't like Cooking Boogie To cook this just for you
It'll be similar to the voting for the The Commissioned Art
concept And again, if there's something Too weird that gets
number one Then we in detail.
But also, weird might be fun.
Yeah, that's what I was thinking.
This is your chance, Denchi.
You want MVP metal?
This is your chance.
You know, something that you didn't think we would make a
song for originally.
This is your chance to get it in there, guys.
Have you heard of, have you guys heard of Hitem before?
It's called, it's a genre called Hitem.
Hit, Hitem.
No, I haven't.
It's in 5-4 time, 2-12 BPM, and...
Super-duper crunchy sound.
212 BPM gold.
What?
That is a very something.
I need to hear this.
Yeah, I'm going to look this up.
Oh, there are examples.
I love the idea of sea shanty.
That'd be so cool.
Yeah.
Sea shanty.
Skar song.
Skar.
Mongolian throat singing.
I think we need some professional training for that one.
That's what you'll be getting.
It doesn't have to be a good song that we made.
Yeah, it doesn't have to be a good song.
But we'll make a song.
And then 30,000.
Each of us has chosen something crazy to do.
So we talk about each of all.
Go, Minta, what have you chosen?
Well, I said that I wanted to play the new Master Collection
of Metal Gear.
So I was like, I'll just do it a one stream.
and now I have to.
Yes, Minto!
Yay!
Woo-hoo!
I believe in you, you can do it.
How long do you think that will be, approximately?
For me?
Ooh.
Maybe, like, over 24 hours or something.
Oh, God.
Do your best, Minto.
Do your best.
And on a show.
Similar note, Phoebe.
Similar note.
I had two different ones to choose from.
I didn't know which one to put, so you couldn't pick
whichever one you like.
I mean, they might both end up happening at this point, but
what we have down right now is that I have attempted three
times in the past to do a 24-hour stream, and I think the
furthest we've ever gotten is 23.5 hours.
I will definitely...
I have to now Hit the 24 hours I will up to a 24 hour stream
Yeah yeah You can do it The other reward was that I Reprise
my hot limit cover With a video of me wearing the hot limit
outfit But There's a tutorial for how to make it with tape
online On TM Revolution's channel There is But I don't know
I don't know at this point.
The 24-hour stream is guaranteed, but on the hot limit, I'll
have to...
Let me think about it a little bit.
As someone says in the chat, Yeah, bye.
Yeah, bye.
24-hour hot limit.
What in the 24-hour hot limit?
I don't know about that.
Vicky seems excited for that.
Yes, of course.
I'm excited to hear you sing always, Phoebe.
I'm so excited.
Yay.
Yeah.
What about you, Vicky?
What would happen?
Yeah, again, I wasn't sure if we were gonna hit this, to be
honest, so I kind of just put this down without really
thinking about it, but I guess I'm doing an IRL gym routine
video.
There's gonna be a little sticker on my face, and I'm gonna
show you guys my gym routine, IRL.
So that'll be fine.
Wow, you can get swole just like Vicky.
With Vicky.
Yeah.
So yeah, it'll take a little bit of, filming and editing and
stuff i hope you guys look forward to that heck yeah so lots
and lots of individual goals you guys are getting that now
because we have in fact hit the 30 000.
we have amazing next up we well we didn't expect to really
get this far but at 67 000.
that's why it 67 000 we have a very very special stretch
goal yes um I am praying for his safety and well-being, but
67,000.
We will make Steiner, our manager, skydive from 28,000 feet
in the air.
Of course, with a guide who will help him stay safe and
well.
I'm that guy.
Yeah.
And not lonely.
Yes.
Yeah.
So he's not going to be lonely up there.
Aw.
I mean, who knows?
Maybe like...
No, I think he...
can do it all on his own i think it's like um you know when
a bird goes to fly for the first time like the parent has to
push them out and just let them let them be the parent
pushing him out all three of us all three of us can we can
we all go to watch
oh we should have him take a camera with him it could be
part of the vacation
I don't know if I'll feel very vacationed with it.
Well, it might for us.
Oh, yeah.
We love you, Steiner.
We love you.
I was thinking, he's like, who knows, maybe we'll get past
67,000.
What if we also got some of the other staff from Setsuna to
join Steiner so that he's not alone and he doesn't feel bad?
We're just recruiting people without their consent.
They're like, they're like, We'd have to talk to them first.
Well, we'd have to talk to them first, but...
Well, I can't believe...
I am so shocked that we are nearly at that, though.
I think it was very much like, oh, yeah, put this down.
But it's amazing that you guys are being so supportive
today.
Thank you so, so much.
Wow, wow.
As you could tell by the number, The skydiving one was kind
of a joke, so you were like, We won't even get close to
that.
Yeah, we're like, I was no way.
But yes.
And then also along with goals, we have some incentives
that...
Yeah.
Go.
So these are, yeah, incentives for individual donations.
So...
Yes.
Who'd like to talk about these?
I know Minto, you had the idea of the raffles.
I think that was such a good idea.
Everyone here involved.
We definitely want to get everything to you guys as soon as
possible.
But we are busy, busy ladies.
So if you donate $5, you will be entered into a deco-checky
raffle.
And there will be five.
I'll do five.
Vicky will do five.
you can have your very own decorated full cute checky yes
and it'll be a physical like physically decorated this time
like our kachian ones yeah we did literally draw on them but
this time it would be hand decorated hand decorated with
lots of love one of a kind yeah one of a kind truly one of a
kind yes yes very exciting and then a ten dollars we have
entry into a one minute custom voice there will be so 30
total one minute custom voice packs really getting those
really getting those in today yeah um 10 per member yes um
so you'll be entered into that raffle for the custom one
minute voice pack again guys we we can have vetoes for this
but but you know we'll we'll do our best we trust dan she we
trust yeah yeah we trust you guys oh and then 25 i think we
had a bit more info on the $25.
Let me just ask...
It was somewhere here.
It's a...
A unique reward.
Nice cloud.
Ow, ow!
One of my traits, guys, is whenever I'm typing quickly, what
I type makes absolutely no sense.
But I think we've gotten to the point where, like, I think
MVP and the sets and the stuff kind of, like, vaguely
understand it because that I'm like used to it.
You think that's...
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's like my own language.
Yeah.
Oh, okay.
So this reward was like a kind donation from Oscar.
Our pal Oscar.
Thank you, Oscar.
Thank you.
And it'll be...
You'll get to enter a raffle to get a free two-hour special
walk-around tour slot at TwitchCon on either Friday or
Sunday of the convention.
So this is especially good for those of you guys that have
plans to go to TwitchCon.
But maybe this will be your reason to go to TwitchCon if you
don't have plans.
And then the winner can use this slot however they want to,
either solo or in a group.
You'll also get TwitchCon 2026 souvenir item from their loot
case.
Ooh.
And this winner can also stream the walk around if they like
as well.
Yeah, so if you've ever seen like how VTubers kind of have a
person to walk around.
and like check out conventions and stuff you are the vtuber
you get and you get your own personalized uh little tour of
of twitch con for two hours yeah you get to go around and
you can be the vtuber you'll be the mvp yeah oh so cool that
sounds amazing thank you so much oscar yeah thank you he's
he's walked many of vtubers around as well you might you
might have seen him with like i think he's walked like
matara around and stuff so yeah yeah yeah we can be the
vtuber virtual virtual con experience all from the comfort
of your own home be a vtuber today be a vtuber for two hours
oh he's done vc's too fine oh awesome that's so cool $50,
you guys will get sent a special Hope for the Day art
background.
This will be a digital background with some special art
commissioned especially for the Hope for the Day stream.
So I hope you guys will look forward to that.
Very nice.
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
Oh, at a hundred, you guys will get a digitally signed photo
card from each of us.
You get three things.
Wow.
Three for one.
300.
100.
But yes, so you'll get one from each of us.
And it's kind of upgraded at the next one.
300.
You'll get...
A 300.
Physical.
In your hand, signed photo card from each of us.
So once again.
From each of us.
A three, four, 300.
But yeah.
Thank you, Kate.
Oh.
Guys, I think we've got to talk about this.
It was, you know, I think people want us to play League of
Legends.
I think they want League of Legends, you know?
I think, I think, like, okay, why don't we do a poll?
Why don't we do a poll, guys?
Like, who is wanting us to play?
Who is not?
Oh, jeez.
Oh, I can't do a poll.
Oh, wait, can you guys do a poll?
Wait, hang on.
It's fine.
They want us to play Valorant instead.
Oh.
Valorant forked my computer.
cute or once.
No way!
Well, rather, I tried to install it to play with my little
sister because she's the Valorant player and then it would
not let me play.
Oh, no!
So sorry, no Valorant.
No, okay, no Valorant.
I don't know.
We'll have something.
Yes.
Or, or League.
Or both at the same time.
Or both?
Yeah, you can have, like, and you'll have subway surfers in
the corner as well.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, we could play Those who want to watch us play League
Watch that and then we'll play something else at the same
time League with the hands Yeah, that's a grass really big
brain Exactly Way surfer with our brains Guys, I literally
just bought one of those like foot pedals Actually, so I
could actually do that Yeah, like a USB foot pedal Wait, you
got one Yeah, I got one, yeah It's got like three inputs
that you can use with your feet Yeah Whoa!
Yeah, it's just what sounds great what did you what do you
plan to do with it oh that's a secret actually something
something that i want to do on stream that will occupy my
hands but i still need to be able to press buttons i wonder
what that could be could be a certain instrument perhaps all
right oh
anyway and then at 300 we have a physically signed photo
card from each member yeah awesome awesome awesome yay um so
thank you so much you guys thank you thank you thank you wow
like uh you guys are just being so hegging generous i can't
but yeah i can't believe we're only hang on how much is that
10 hang on i can't 15 no is that right no yeah no 15 000
away right from from the from the skydiving oh is that right
wow wow amazing oh 51 000 was apparently okay we're doing
league again so guys we're doing league again we're doing
league again we're doing league again guys who who i didn't
even notice that i didn't either i don't see the the goals
These are getting out of hand.
Yes.
But yeah, thank you guys for reaching so many of the goals.
Nearly all of them within less than an hour of our stream
starting.
That's amazing, you guys.
Well, we're still gonna hang out and we're gonna play games
and we're gonna be silly.
Mm-hmm.
Yes.
We have a whole schedule for today.
We do.
We'll talk about the schedule a little bit.
Which order are we doing?
I'm actually not sure which order we're doing things.
So right now, we're in the yapp section.
Oh, yes.
And actually, like, oh, you guys know already we can yapp.
We're yappers.
We're going to be doing some friend slot gaming in about 15,
20 minutes or so.
Friend slot.
Install that.
I think I did.
Where's this time, if not?
But there's a game that was recommended to us that
apparently is Densetsu Core, so we're going to be giving
that a try.
We'll be giving that a try.
But then there's also lots of other things that we could
switch to if we want to as well.
5 p.m.
or, sorry, an hour and 15 or 20 minutes from now.
That'll be the next section, which will be script reading,
out of character script reading.
Yeah!
What could that be?
Fun.
We all prepared stuff for that.
The $1,000 goal.
And then our last hour is going to be our very, very first
VR chat stream together with silly models.
Yeah, we just went so, you know, we've got our proper, you
know, first VR chat stream coming because you guys unlocked
that goal.
This one's just like a kind of silly one today, aren't we?
We're using silly models and we're just exploring around and
just having a fun time yeah but we'll do like a proper you
know stream with our proper models and things for for you
guys's incentive so thank you so much yay yeah thank you oh
apparently chat can hear steam just fyi okay i i know
game already installed you guys yes yes she did she did yeah
yeah yeah yeah no can we just take a moment to say thank you
so much to um mint over hosting today and and getting
everything ready there's lots to prepare for today the oh
thank you mint though thank you of course of course of
course thank you mint oh yes all right wow yes oh i cannot
believe it i'm just i'm just in i'm just in awe right now
everyone's generosity right so great thank you everybody and
all you know every dollar raised today fuels real world
education and suicide prevention programs so you guys are
doing great work and thank you so much thank you so so much
it's truly a fantastic uh cause that means a lot to the
three of us so uh yeah it's it's just you know i i think
Obviously, it's really fun to do these like fun streams and
stuff, but, you know, I'm just so grateful, so grateful to
you guys and so grateful for all your generosity and it
really means a lot.
So thank you guys.
Thank you.
Thank you guys.
It really is a really, really important cause as well.
You know, I think that this stigma that a lot of people have
had about mental health for a long while.
while um kind of contributes to why people can be a little
scared to get help or stay silent about things um that are
that are either happening to them or the people around them
so um this really this really is helping to break that
stigma down and smash the stigma and take action yeah yeah
where do you guys want to go for a vacation a map yeah where
do we want to go so many so many places vacation spots right
i don't know the beach beach episode we could definitely
have a beach episode uh oh i'm imagining us all in those
little you know the little floaties you know just like
chilling with like a with like a cold drink
someone said go to miami again go to miami again oh yeah
that time we went to miami time we went to miami yeah we
didn't really go on the beach in miami but we could totally
go on the beach in in totally miami this totally miami theme
park yeah we could do we can definitely do we could
definitely do more theme parks mongolia for the palace
castle my dream one day one day guys It's so expensive.
Avoid volcanoes.
Well, maybe we want to look at a volcano, maybe.
I'm going to dive on in.
That'll be our pool.
Whoa.
The pool!
We'll bring a floaty with you.
You won't need to vlog it.
We'll be on the news.
You guys were yokai.
We can survive.
It's all good.
Oh, it might be a little hot.
It might be a little...
Oh, yeah.
Yeah, guys, I think we should take our...
Actually, that's a really good point.
I think we should take our vacation on March 19th, 2027.
I think we should make sure our vacation is at that point.
I think our vacation should be either the UK or the US or
somewhere where the Sonic Movie 4 is showing.
On time, yeah, yes, yes.
Does Japan get it delayed?
Yes, it is delayed.
That's so sad because Sonic is Japanese.
I know.
right what the heck well well i think technically he's meant
to be american but yet but yes the games are fun right he's
chilly dogs that's true he's like he like protects the
president of the u.s or something like that yeah exactly um
so yeah that's what i vote yeah march 19th 2027 vacation are
you going to are you going to do you have plans to travel so
that you can see it on release day um i'm very tempted to
fly somewhere to make sure i because if anybody should you
should right i can't always i can't open twitter for like
two weeks like i literally won't be able to use twitter at
all exactly they they should invite you to the red carpet oh
oh thanks guys oh thank you thank you so much you have to
wear your sonic or shadow fit to the to the yeah the son or
the shadow blow up outfit the shadow blow up outfit yeah i'm
gonna get i'm thinking of getting one of those i was like i
was like half tempted i might do my workout video for the
stretch goal in that outfit if I can make it happen.
Yeah!
Amazing.
Would it be a blue carpet?
Because it's Sonic.
Yeah, would it be a blue carpet?
It should be.
Wait, what is... So the fourth movie has Amy in it?
Or...
Yes.
Oh, God, I screamed at the end of the third movie.
Yes!
Screaming and crying.
yeah oh i'm so excited um and then what yeah what other
places for vacation yeah the the dinosaur onsen but if we
were like going outside of japan outside of japan i've
always wanted to go to venice because because like because
of aria the animation and because italian food but then like
i've been told it's stinky it does stink it's really that
stinky yeah And it's super busy too.
Like...
Yeah.
I mean, it's nice, but I feel like...
I wonder if there's any like Venice likes out there.
Well, I went to like rural, like this town in rural Italy,
the same trip I went to Venice.
And I liked that a lot better.
Yeah, I liked being able to like walk around the town square
and get a little coffee and things.
And that was all very nice.
There's Australia.
Australia?
We have to go back.
We need to go this time.
I want to go on the wild wombat tour.
We need to go find them in the wild.
No!
I was going to say there's canals in, um, uh, Las Vegas.
Oh!
Are they all so stinky or?
There's a Venice Canal in one of the hotels of Las Vegas.
We can just go to Vegas.
Oh, I don't mind going to Omega Mart in Vegas for a while.
Oh, wait, that'd be fine.
What's Omega?
Oh, yes.
How do you explain?
It's like an art...
The best grocery store.
Exhibit.
It is a grocery store, but there's like hidden tunnels
behind the...
Behind the...
It's like shelving and stuff.
Hidden tunnels...
Whoa.
Yeah.
Oh my gosh, I love hidden tunnels.
I always...
I was always obsessed.
You know when people build those houses where it's like, and
then we pull back the bookcase, and then there's a tunnel to
this other room.
And I'm like, I wanted that so bad.
You know, I still want that.
Oh, my gosh.
That's so cool.
Okay, yeah.
Omega mark.
Go in Omega mark.
That's always been a cool, like, childhood goal, too,
though.
To, like, have those hidden rooms in your house.
Or to have a treehouse.
It feels so like I have too much money.
And I'm just building secret tunnels in my house.
And it's like, yeah.
Let's go.
It's so cool.
Yeah.
We're all haunted house tour.
Oh no.
Guys, you guys would love Greece.
Yeah, we should go to Greece.
Greece!
There's too many places.
So pretty.
They're like the white and blue houses and the sea is so
nice and the food is so good.
Ooh.
Yeah, delicious, delicious.
Delicious.
Make me hungry.
Yeah.
I'm already hungry.
Oh no!
Blueprints enthusiast.
I do, I do, I do love blueprints.
Wait, I, I, oh my gosh, wait, this also pertains a little
bit to you.
I found the, um, the outer wild vinyls for, like, not,
people, they were, they've been out of print, and so people
have been selling them for, like, $200.
And so I found them, but when I found them, I discovered
that the same company has a blueprints vinyl for, like,
yeah.
Whoa!
Oh my gosh.
Made for you, Vicky.
I know.
No, I feel the same way about Outer Wild as I did about
Blueprints.
Like, I'm just obsessed.
Like, I keep thinking about it.
It's like, when am I playing it next?
I need to play it again.
I'm obsessed.
I heard it's really good, but I'm very bad at Outer Wild.
I'm very bad.
No, it's okay.
Oh, have you tried it?
I used to, I've done a few streams for it like years ago.
and it's the one where you like drive the spaceship right
yeah yeah yeah yeah i'm so bad at driving the spaceship oh
don't worry me too yeah all the time me too yeah i was like
i feel like i'm not playing the game right and then i just
didn't touch it anymore for a long time oh no don't feel it
i hope oh god well i've only done one stream so far but i'm
already hooked so i'm so excited the game you just dying a
bajillion times so don't worry it's like part of the game
yeah i totally didn't crash the ship and then yeah it just
like exploded in front of me i never crashed the ship even
once you know but you serious well really never wow that's
so cool wait wow but i feel like phoebe i mean no pressure
obviously but like i think you would really love the story
That's what I really do want to get back to it sometime,
because I didn't get to experience like any other story so
far.
So I would like to try it again.
Please, so I can reach the all just be like, I don't know,
let's play it.
Yeah.
Well, when I get back from my trip then, I think that'll be
one of the first things I pick up again.
Thanks.
Once we all complete it and it's, you know, we can talk
about the spoilers, we can all get in a group chat.
I know.
It's one of my brain rods.
I'm always thinking about Outer Wilds.
I'm not going to lie.
Yeah, really?
Yes.
I'm so excited to continue it.
Wow.
So cool.
Yeah, no, it's really good.
Any other games you guys have been playing recently that
have been like, I'm obsessed.
I'm loving it.
Expedition 33.
Yeah, you've been playing too much lately.
Like, after, with like, the Torgaon.
and being gone so long, I've probably forgotten how to play,
but when I was playing it, I was obsessed.
And I still kind of am.
I'm always telling people, you're in my Steam family.
Go, go play the game while I'm traveling.
Go borrow the game from me.
Please, I beg of you.
Understandable, understandable.
Are you learning French?
Are you able to speak French now that you're playing this
game?
Yes, mademoiselle.
Oh, wow!
Oh, so lovely.
Play blue!
Oh!
Amazing!
Oh, so cool!
I have been playing a game called Control.
Oh, yeah!
How is it?
Oh, I've heard good things.
It's actually, oh my gosh, my brain is like, I want to play
more Control.
Control is so fun!
Oh!
Yeah, I...
Because I'm kind of trying to go through like the remedy
game scene.
series so like with you know i played alan wake now i'm on
control then i'll do alan wake 2 and then control 2 because
that's coming out and then probably max pain and just going
through and actually though oh also crime scene cleaner yeah
you've done a lot of crime scene cleaner yeah it actually
has a story and it's like it's like power wash cleaner but
like so it's i don't know a cool story about it.
That's like so fun.
It's so fun.
I realized I thought it was more just like, yeah, like just
one of those, you know, yapping play kind of games.
It is.
But then, yeah, there is like a plot happening and like it's
fun.
Like it's just yeah.
I recommend that too.
If you want something that's a little like like Power Wash
but also a little more plot driven.
So ooh.
Sounds interesting.
Yeah, it's very cool.
Ooh.
So exciting.
Heck yeah.
Six feet.
Wait, yeah, no, 56.
We're on 56K already.
Amazing.
Oh, boy.
Nearly $10,000 to go until the Steiner skydive.
Nearly there.
Yeah, if we can get there in three hours, you guys, then.
Yeah.
There we go.
Evil laughter
But yeah What happens after we pass 67k We have not thought
that far We didn't think I mean we're not there yet But we
didn't think we would get close So yeah You guys are so so
generous Thank you I mean we can always think of more Things
on the spot or I don't have no idea like Yeah, maybe you
guys can help us come up with some rewards for things like
Like a hundred I feel like they might just give bat suits
though They the good intentions of den she right guys.
Bye.
Bye den she Good intentions
We're good not evil
Guys, speaking of games, you wanna, you wanna become our new
forms?
Oh yeah!
Yeah!
We're gonna transform you guys.
I mean, to be honest, it's kind of similar to, you know,
this is just how we look, to be honest, I think.
Don't you think?
Wait, are we playing, which, wait, are we gnoming?
Yeah!
Okay!
You guys won!
I was like, wait, we do whatever we're doing.
Um, wait, I kind of want to, I want, I want to propose,
maybe like, if anybody has some ideas for incentives, you
could put them in the Den Setsu Discord, and then maybe,
like, think that maybe some people, mods can, can go through
them and propose them and send them to us, and we could, we
could add them maybe.
Gensetsu live chat.
Maybe put some suggestions.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Perhaps.
Maybe.
Good plan.
So then we can have some more incentives for you guys.
Yeah.
Okay.
Let me start up.
That'd be awesome.
Let me start up some no's.
I assure you the mods will be super fair.
Okay.
They will be.
Because I think the mods work for us.
And if the mods want a paycheck, they need to be fair.
Oh, are we doing in-game boys for this or?
That's what I'm wondering.
Oh, great question.
What would you prefer for the setup?
You know, probably because it's only one POV, let's not.
Yeah, okay.
This is the same.
So you just have to uncheck the thing, right?
for the laughs what do you guys think because sometimes it's
fun to hear someone screaming all the way in the background
but i'd say because we're probably just gonna be like
yapping as well right i'd say maybe just keep to keep to
discord maybe but let me work out how to turn off um
voice chat okay i know okay voice chat oh there's a tutorial
why i always have a hard time saying to tutorial tutorial oh
do i mean febe i have words like that too mine's some
submarine some some i don't even know what you're trying to
say submarine submarine oh oh yeah yeah yeah i'm gonna
shrink us a little bit shrink us all to size Maybe we don't
need the tutorial.
I did it.
The tutorial.
Oh, you did it?
Oh, do we need to do it?
No, no, no.
I meant I was happy that I was able to say it to the
tutorial.
Oh, yeah.
But then I screwed up again.
No, don't worry.
I think it's a great sign that one of the noses holding some
pants.
Okay, we'll find out what this game is all about.
Oh, no.
Wait, I'm going to shrink it.
We'll put it over this way.
I think the one driving is Mintho.
Me?
Wait, who?
Yeah.
I love that odd of us where I'm driving, but I literally
don't have a driver's license.
Oh, yes.
I do.
Wait, aren't you like the one of us who does not?
Yeah.
Oh, but you're the one driving.
I think so, yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
I think it's great that I'm the one driving, but the one
without a driver.
license.
But I'm glad you guys, you know, saw me in that role.
Thank you.
It was such good art.
Thanks, Symphony.
Yeah, I love that art.
So good.
Do do do do do.
I like the music.
Well, is it okay if somebody else hosts it?
Oh, I can host.
Yeah.
Oh, are you hosting?
Okay.
private game i assume yeah okay and then how do i wait i
started a i started a private game can you guys wait oh yeah
let me see do you like invite us on yeah is there a password
or yeah let me see if there's like a place this seems to be
some kind of starting hub spirit catcher stockpile start
of creation okay this is not telling me how to invite people
oh oh oh there we go okay i'll just click everything oh wait
join a friends game through the steam friends list so i
think i just joined off of you oh yeah yeah if you can it
just kind of like join game okay yeah i think it works wait
i don't it's not like me wait join game if you click on uh
Phoebe's name in your Steam friend list.
I think it should have an option to join games.
Oh, there it is.
Oh, there we go.
And then...
Oh, oh.
Oh, what is happening?
I'm in somebody's mouth.
What's happening?
Oh, oh.
Yeah.
What the...
Oh, wow.
Yeah.
This is what you went into.
It's like, yeah.
I don't know why.
Is there a purpose?
Can we touch it?
Ah!
Whoa!
I got sneezed out.
The tongue spat me back out.
It's a female.
You love your lot.
Oh, I...
What's in this well?
Well of creation.
We can make things.
So this game, guys, is called Burglain Nose.
Oh, shoot.
Everybody's lagging.
One second.
Oh, no, I ain't.
Let's see.
No camera, Bob.
Oh, blah, blah, blah.
maybe that's better oh for some reason there's nudity in
this gnome game but we turned that off oh oh yes is it off
yes yes it is okay excellent oh is there a setting for that
somewhere yes but i'd rather not look it's auto turned off
luckily okay good good good good okay awesome what you You
can turn it on.
You can choose.
Oh, oh, no.
Oh, no.
Oh, my gosh.
Okay, if I go in the mouth, will it?
Okay, there we go.
Oh, um.
Victoria Roman.
Um, don't worry.
Am I back?
You're back.
He's a- We're still back.
He's chomping on you, actually.
He's like, I'm trapped.
Don't get out.
Try crouching.
Okay.
There you go.
Beautiful.
Lovely.
Am I out?
Oh, I'm still crouching.
Okay.
Nice.
Very nice.
Oh, can you fall?
No secrets around.
Why is this sound so... Oh, who's in there?
Ew.
Oh, there's someone in there?
Oh, there's some butterflies.
Very nice.
Yeah, this is a nice little area.
What are we doing?
Yeah, very nice.
Oh, there's... Start the game.
Stockpile.
We gotta go burgle some things so we can...
Oh, okay.
When you guys are ready, let me know.
Oh, yeah.
I'm ready for some...
I'm ready, yeah.
Yeah.
Oops, I'm on fire.
Oh, let's hope you're not on fire when we start the game.
I think we're okay.
Yeah.
Are we good?
It's loading.
The lavender grass.
It's a very beautiful area.
Oh.
Oh, wow.
Wow.
Ooh.
Oh, my God.
There you guys are.
Where are we dropping, chat?
Where are we dropping?
Thank you, bus driver.
Is this Fortnite?
Okay, right.
Okay.
Right, guys.
There's the house, I'm guessing.
That we've got a burglar.
Can I?
Wait, this is a...
You guys, this is a metacamelian.
Right.
Oh, wait.
I'm inside.
Wait.
Which is happening?
Where are you?
Whoa.
Oh, there you are.
This is a metacamelian, I think.
Oh, we can get up higher.
That does look like a Meta Chameleon.
Who are you?
It looks like a pregnant Meta Chameleon.
Oh, that's just like my fanfix.
What?
Alright.
Wait, I'm so short.
I can't get up the stairs.
Where are you guys?
We're here.
Being short.
Welcome to our world.
Yeah, because it's what it feels like to be you guys.
Mint and Phoebe Simulia.
later how do we get in let's see if there's a way here oh
smart smart smart but then how do you open it huh i'm gonna
check for any holes around the property yeah we can oh dear
oh dear um oh god what happened whoa oh dear are you in
don't don't jump don't jump from the window is what i will
say what happened i'm bleeding you're bleeding Are you okay?
Where am I?
Where did you go?
Did you noclip through the...
Oh!
Oh my god, I flung myself far, far, far, far away.
I was like, oh my arms are stretchy and then it flung...
Where am I?
Phoebe!
Oh!
Holy moly!
I see!
My hand is so long!
Whoa!
No, if you do that, you might end up where I am at.
Where'd you go?
How did you?
I don't see any houses for miles.
I'm in a forest.
Where am I?
I think I died.
Oh, no, I'm...
Oh my god.
No, no, no, you're fine.
You're fine.
No, I'm like crawling.
Wait, help me!
Oh, I can revive you.
I can revive you.
Oh, are you okay?
I lost my feet.
Oh.
Wait, my feet lifts?
No, you have feet.
So whose feet are they?
Wait, Phoebe, are they your feet?
Oh, come here.
They might be.
I have to cross a river.
I don't know where I am.
Where are you?
do this wait how did you do that yeah let's go find you
before we go in yeah i so i hung off of the window ledge and
then i flung myself and i guess i flew so far that i'm not
even near the spawn anymore i'm like not at the house so
like whereabouts are you oh hang on we see we see something
Another gnome.
Are you?
Excuse me.
Is that not?
Is that not Phoebe Chan Chibi?
That's not.
That's a skin walker.
I found you faker.
Wait, what?
Um...
What just happened?
I don't know.
Oh, I hear it.
Someone just flushed the toilet.
Oh, I just kissed the gnome.
Oh, my God.
There's a bee coming after me.
A bee?
Oh, if I was there i could talk to them no oh he's made me
confused wait what's happening whoa whoa get that bee off no
no no i just died attack the bee attack the bee oh i also
just yeah the bee sting it was too much oh phoebe you're the
only one left alive where are you as you can see i was
across the river before i was all the way yonder you're
meant to be able to go there i don't know Did you just spawn
out of the map or something?
I don't even know.
How do you get back over the fence?
Yeah, let me see if there's a way.
Um...
You might need to just like...
Maybe there's a restart.
Like respawn.
Girl, I think...
I think you're like...
I think you just spawned out of the map.
Yeah, you have to...
Maybe like your character needs to die or something maybe.
So that you can...
Yeah, I think so.
Oh, your arms.
Oh...
Yeah, I think I do need to die.
Yeah, I think so.
Oh no!
Okay.
Round over.
Well, let's go home, I guess.
Okay, yeah, let's...
Now we can get back in the house.
Round over.
Is it gonna automatically restart?
I think so.
Hopefully.
Oh yeah, there we go.
Ooh.
Oh.
I don't know how I feel now.
The birth of gnome.
I don't know how I feel now knowing that's Somebody said
that this was very Densetsu core.
Now playing this again.
Yeah, what do you guys mean?
Don't know how I feel.
Gnome report.
Oh, we have a gnome report.
Open a window.
Oh.
We got nothing.
What?
Up?
Oh, come on.
I wonder if it's like, um, I wonder if it's like, what's it
called?
That game where you're in space and you're collecting
things.
Oh, yes.
Yes, yes, yes.
So you have to complete a certain number of tasks, I think.
Yeah, I think so.
I think it's like that.
What was it called again?
I forget.
Yeah, like a quota game.
Lethal Company.
Oh, Lethal Company.
Yeah, yeah.
I'm thinking Lethal Company gnome version.
Okay, okay.
All right, we got this this time.
We got this.
Let's go.
We'll find a way in there.
We're loading.
I'm sure we will.
Wow, Lethal Company.
That brings back memories.
That was fun.
I loved Lethal Company.
Do we all have to do it?
Because one of the goals was to kiss a gnome, which I
definitely did.
I kissed the gnome.
But it said that we hadn't done it.
Maybe we all have to do it.
Maybe it's because we died.
Oh, maybe.
Yeah, maybe you have to not die and do the goals at the same
time.
Wait, there's a gnome right there.
We can kiss him.
Yeah.
Where'd he go?
Wait, here, here.
Kiss that gnome.
How do you kiss him?
I don't know, actually.
I managed to kiss the other one.
Maybe you have to reach your hands out.
Mwah, mwah, mwah.
Am I going to have to kiss the one like around the back of
the house?
How'd you kiss him?
Oh, you kissed him?
I'll try grabbing him and then...
Watch out for the bees!
The bee is back!
Oh no!
Uh oh.
I think I am confused, but I'm okay.
I'll drag you with me.
Wait, how do we get that bee off of you?
Oh yeah, what the heck?
There's gotta be a way to open the window, right?
Yeah.
the house is different vicky can you turn around real quick
i'm gonna yes i'm gonna try to get the b oh yeah it's so
cute though it is on me yeah it's on oh wait wait stop
moving stop moving oh you got it oh i got i have it in my
inventory oh i'm oh oh are you okay she threw it and smashed
it oh okay all right to open these windows there's gotta be
right there's gotta be right maybe all three of us all three
of us maybe need to yeah maybe we need the strength of all
the no wait yeah here no no i just requires one oh um oh my
god oh yeah oh yeah oh nice good job phoebe watch out for
the mouse trap oh how do you i don't know understand the
controls i think burgle that oh geez oh geez i just threw
Nice.
Can I get cheese?
This one cheese.
Cheese.
Oh, cheese.
All right, let's see what we've got here.
Nothing.
Where do we bring the stuff to?
Oh, yeah.
Okay, nothing.
Wait, we got a dog?
We got a dog?
You can burgle the dog?
I don't know, maybe.
Yeah.
What have we got to do?
Have we got to find their money?
This place is empty.
I don't think they have anything worth stealing, I'll be
honest.
Yeah.
Oh, they have a cat!
They have a cat!
They have a cockroach as well!
Come here, you!
I'm going to burgle this.
They live like this?
Come here, come here, come here!
I think I found something of worth.
Oh?
I don't know what to do with it, though.
Oh!
The cockroach?
might have...
Ah, there's a man!
Watch out!
Where?
Oh, no!
Oh, my God.
He'll never see us in here.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
We're totally fine.
Phoebe, where are you?
Oh, I'm on a shelf.
Nice beard.
Oh, thank you.
Oh, very nice beard.
You've got there.
Oh, she's...
Um...
Ew, get that out of my face.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
There are things.
Slap that.
You slap that.
Go back to sleep, Grandpa.
Oh, he's got a gun!
Oh, no.
Oh, no, he doesn't.
I thought that was a gun.
Oh.
What is it?
It was the thing I was trying to steal.
His console.
Push this.
Oh.
Why?
Oh, shoot.
Why is he doing this?
Okay, can you leave us B now, please?
He is camping.
Phoebe, where are you?
Uh, in the, in the box on a shelf.
Uh, try to get out of the box.
Task complete.
Wait, what just happened?
Oh, task complete.
What do we do?
Uh, I got marbles.
I don't know if that was a task.
Okay, I can't get out of this freaking box.
Oh, oh, oh, over here.
I see somebody running.
Oh, come here, here, here.
I'm good.
I'm moving it.
Oh, oh, thank you.
Yeah.
Oh, thank you.
Nice.
Look, up there, there's a globe and stuff.
Oh, there's stuff.
There's stuff.
Okay, we're parkouring.
It's hard to climb.
Oh, yeah.
Wait.
Maybe I can reach the globe.
No?
I don't think we have enough.
10 minutes left to do what?
I don't understand.
We're meant to be doing.
Uh-oh.
I think you might have seen us.
Uh, I, I, I, I went on top of the edge of the box.
Oh, okay, okay.
I'm going to, I'm going to start shoving things down.
Yeah, yeah.
Nice idea.
This, this, this thing.
Hey.
Oh.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Oh, you think we just have to bring stuff back?
I think so, right?
I see, I see.
Just anything.
I assumed we had to, like, find this safe or something.
Oh, no.
Oh, no, no, no, no!
Bring it back!
He's putting me in the oven!
No!
Get him out of it!
Someone help me!
I'm gonna help you.
No!
You need to live!
Getting you out!
Getting you out, man.
Oh, no!
Okay.
Oh, he's taking me to...
He's taking me to...
I'm tired.
Oh, thank you.
Thank you.
No, baby, where are you?
Where are you taking me?
He's taking me to the...
Oh, no!
Not the toilet!
Not the turrets!
No!
Oh, wait.
No, that got me out.
I'm outside.
Bro, you literally have cockroaches in your house.
Yeah, this is...
Oh, gosh.
Oh, my God.
I'm stuck.
I'm coming for you.
Oh, he's...
It's okay.
I ended up outside.
It flushed me to the outdoors.
Oh, nice, nice.
You guys can...
Oh, okay.
I'll come back inside.
Okay.
As soon as I can.
We could both go down there.
Oh, no.
Try and get some more stuff, then.
Like some these.
Well, those look like some fancy towels.
Oh!
Did I go boo?
Okay.
J-na.
Mink, fandom?
What happened?
I...
Oh my god, what is that?
Oh my god.
Who is that?
Hello?
Oh, guys, where are you?
I'm dead.
I'm spectating Phoebe.
What does that mean?
Oh, no, the boy is following me.
Guys, you can fast travel.
You can fast travel through the mouse tunnels.
Oh, he's following you.
Mouse tunnels.
Oh, can you come up here, dude?
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
He's really fast up and down.
Yeah, oh my God, you're so fast.
Ow, okay.
Come here.
Can you come up?
Yeah, he's up.
He's up.
Whoa.
Who is this?
Your friend.
Be careful of the mouse traps, and also be careful of
grabbing anything.
Yes.
This is what I aim for at the gym.
This is what you guys will look like if you follow Vicky's
video.
Oh, yeah.
um bb are you good no oh yeah yeah he's so loud though the
guy's gonna come he's gonna hear him i know right
oh maybe that's what we meant to do maybe we meant to use
this guy to like distract the other guy yeah but he follows
us yeah but yeah exactly well i want i want min-to-toe back
How do I get this?
I'll just grab something to steal.
Yeah, just grab something.
I think getting out will be a little bit of...
There's a globe right there.
Oh, yeah, okay, that sounds better.
Oh, can I steal this one?
This guy's so loud.
He's so loud.
I'm gonna go check on my cat real quick.
I'll be right back.
Okay!
Phoebe, how do we get out?
That's a very good question.
Bro is literally right there.
Oh, bro, bro, bro, no.
No!
Oh, but he's got us in both hands.
Oh, shoot.
Oh, he ripped my arms off.
Oh, no.
Vicky.
Where are you?
Where'd you go, Phoebe?
Where'd you go?
I'm outside.
Oh, why is this guy so...
He has no head.
What happened?
There's no head.
Ew, ew.
Why do you look like that?
Oh, no, no, no.
he's just walking backwards.
You can't get me if I'm outside, bro.
Ha-ha-ha-ha-ha.
Uh-oh.
Watch out!
Where are you?
Can I come save you?
Me?
Oh, you're on the table.
Okay, and I can see Phoebe on the table.
Yeah.
Oh, no.
Five minutes left!
Row is so loud.
What happened to him?
Did he get distracted by the guy?
Oh, hi.
Hi.
I don't know.
I think you're distracted by the guy.
Now's our time.
Go, go, go, go.
How do we get the stuff out of the window.
I don't understand.
Oh, he's on his way back, you guys.
He's right behind you.
You don't understand how to get it out.
Do we have to go out the front door or something?
Where is the front door?
Oh, here.
Yeah, you're right by it.
Oh, he's right behind you, Vicky.
Oh, he didn't notice you.
You're fine.
I tried to steal.
How do I...
How do I open the door?
I'm moving this chair in hopes that we can...
We are apparently 2k away from...
From...
Skydiving!
Wow.
Thank you guys.
Oh, nice.
Yeah, you can move it.
Okay, there's a chair here.
There's a chair here in the...
I'm also moving the stool.
Yeah, yeah.
Very slowly.
Phoebe, I think you could come help Vicky because this one
looks like it'll be easy.
Where is it?
Oh, this one?
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice.
The power of two.
Okay, put it by the front door.
I think we're near there right now.
I hope.
I'm gonna keep an eye out for him.
We got five minutes though.
Yeah, I'm looking for him too.
Don't worry.
Thank you.
Okay.
All right, grab the globe.
Oh, nice, nice.
That was a door opening.
Did you open it?
Yeah, I think you need to move the stool though.
Oh, okay.
Okay.
I'm moving.
I'm moving it.
Okay.
Oh.
Come on, dude.
Oh, come on.
Go, Phoebe.
Go.
Use the upper body shield.
straight you do it oh oh my god no no oh no i guess it
opened what you closed it did open it i think what we need
to do is put the stool here maybe yeah yeah yeah on the sup
next to it okay let's grab it let's grab it okay take take
some take some loot he's on his way guys he's got a rocket
launcher
I think I might have been too late.
No, you're good.
You're good.
Wait, did that not destroy the door to the place?
Did it destroy the door?
Oh, no, it didn't.
It looked like it did.
He brought the stool back.
Wait, I think he's dead.
I think it backfired on him.
He's laying down.
Oh, shoot.
Come on.
Grandpa's taking a nap.
Yeah, now's the time.
Take it, take it, take it.
Yeah!
That door right there.
No way.
Where did he get that from?
I find them, bro.
There's no way he's getting up any time soon after that,
right?
Yeah, yeah, right?
He's taking a long half.
No, what the heck?
What's that?
Oh, what's that?
What is that?
Oh, my gosh.
Who is that?
Oh, my marbles.
Excuse me.
Oh.
You're just laying it down and taking it.
What?
Steiner, prepare yourself.
Oh my gosh, there's $500 left!
Oh my gosh!
He should have never proposed it.
That was all him, by the way, you guys.
We didn't even ask him to do this.
He was like, what if I skydive it?
Alright, I think we got closer, guys.
We know how to open the door now at least.
Yeah, yeah.
I think if we opened it earlier, it would have been fine.
I think maybe those guys came because it said we had five
it's left maybe once we once the time's up they just arrive
i was just gonna say yeah maybe he like comes and destroys
you because there was no way oh come on we opened the window
we did one of those things oh man man there it is okay
guys let me should we should we get a message can we get of
your feelings.
Okay.
The message of your feelings.
Yeah.
Oh my gosh.
Guys, you did it.
You did it.
He sent us the concerned frog emoji.
Oh.
Yeah, he did.
Oh, who's on fire?
Oh.
Uh-oh.
She's back.
Oh.
Oh, you're back.
All right.
A little toasty, but that's okay.
Just a little bit toasty.
Bang, bang, bang.
Thank you so much, you guys.
Thank you.
Wait, where did you guys go?
Did you?
Oh, okay.
There's Middow.
I'm good.
And, okay.
Goodbye.
Something, something, bloom again.
Blit.
Wow!
Thank you guys!
And then we'll still, after this game, we can look at some
of the things that you guys have suggested and we can, I
don't know, maybe make another stretch goal.
Who knows?
I know, where do we go from here?
I don't know!
Yeah!
We seem like we have some great suggestions from you guys
already, so that's exciting.
Yeah!
Thank you!
I saw one of them was Vicky.
He cleans everybody's keyboard because she still owes us a
cleaning of her own keyboard.
Guys, I need to get the camera, like the special, you know,
you know, the camera you guys recommended to me.
I still need to buy it.
And then I'll clean it.
But sure, you know what?
You know, they can't be worse than my keyboard, so sure.
I think it'll be a much better experience.
Maybe.
Yes, I think so.
I have a feeling my keyboard's probably the worst one.
Do we want to start another game?
Yes.
I feel like we've kind of like got the hang of it a little
bit now.
We know how to open the window.
We know how to get the door open.
We get the items.
We got this.
Open the door.
Get out of there.
All right.
We've got this.
If we want, we can go for the door first.
Perhaps.
What?
Someone just suggested mods.
swimsuit calendar what what all right here we go i think
we'll lose subscribers from that let's go i think we're
kissing the gnomes they want us to kiss all the gnomes
there's no window to get in Huh?
I think we have to go around a different way.
Back door?
Yeah, let's try the back.
Let's try the back.
Oh, we have to kiss all the gnomes?
I think so.
Wait, there's one here.
Narahado, narahado.
Oh, I kissed him.
Narahado gnome.
I had a big old kissy sound.
Oh, there's a bee.
There's a bee.
Oh, oh, was that what's happened?
Oh, oh, oh.
That sounded moist.
Eee!
Ouch!
No, B, no!
Here's the window!
Guys, they found it!
Oh!
We found one.
Oh, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice.
Oh, he's asleep right here.
Let's go open the door maybe?
Yeah, let's do that first.
Nothing to see here.
Yeah, guys, those little mouse hatches, you can use those
for quick teleport.
oh wait this this is a very nicely positioned oh no no okay
no we still have to be the door doesn't it we can't carry
items up oh what what oh do we need oh oh we already we
already need the thing okay okay oh okay i hope thank you oh
he's there he's there he's there he's there
This is good.
Yeah, open the door for us.
Oh yeah.
Thank you.
Who is currently in his hand though?
Me.
Okay.
He's opening another door.
Thank you so much, my guy.
Oh, and another.
He opened the front door.
He just threw you out.
He can't see us.
Oh, yeah, he just left the front door open.
Thanks, dude.
Oh, nice.
Wow.
easiest game i'm taking what is this oh i don't know it
looks cool though yeah i'm taking it home
okay let me get up on the chair i saw like a nice oh my gosh
are you okay i'm gonna take some of this fruit i'm dead
sorry oh oh it's okay oh no what happened it was it was a
bomb it exploded oh people are saying it was a landmine it
exploded um a landmine why do i keep dying guys this guy
stepped up his game i'm gonna take one of his fancy plates
yeah take a fancy plate fancy plate that's gotta be worth
decent amount right guys i don't really go it doesn't let me
take it just fell out of my hand yeah it fell out of your
hand yeah yeah that is so unfair what the heck that's what
happened that's what happened what It's like the raccoon
that sticks the...
It's like my butterfingers just like...
Alright, okay, fancy dog bowl, sure.
Also, they have a dog bowl.
I have not seen a dog.
The magic chameleon helps you bring stuff back.
Oh, it does.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, Vicky!
Oi, oi!
Oh!
Let me out!
He's putting you in the fishes!
How dare you!
Oh, no!
Is he still in there?
Keep me!
No, he's not.
He's not.
Or I don't think so.
No, it doesn't look like it.
Yeah, you're good.
He is so rude.
Don't worry, guys.
I'm trying to see if I can get out myself.
Okay, hold on.
Do I need to get, like, a bench?
Let me out!
This is what Vicky...
gets for not bathing.
Guys, every other day's supremacy, okay?
Showering.
What is he doing?
Forcing me to shower every day?
Horrible.
How could he?
Oh my gosh.
What do I...
10 minutes left.
We could just... Is it just Phoebe right now?
We could just restart and respawn.
We could.
We want.
If you prefer.
Yeah, would you like to...
Yeah, we could do that.
Because, like, I'm just...
Yeah, I cannot figure out how to get out of there.
Oh, he's right there.
Oh, he is right there.
Where the heck did he...
Oh, he's watching TV.
Minto can be revived, apparently.
Oh, really?
Oh, I can?
Uh...
Oh, from the...
Oh, it says...
Oh, revive Minto at the orb.
Oh, the spirit catcher.
Oh!
The crystal purple ball.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay, okay.
Yuppie!
Don't take the landmine.
And then maybe we can figure out together how...
how to yeah okay let's go let's get vicky yeah okay ponder
ponder me ponder he's making me take a ball off yeah you're
gonna be squeaky clean whether you like it or not no he's
still right there can you jump on my head phoebe let's see
doesn't look like i lift you
let's try the kitchen maybe there's a Is this...
Wait, you can stand on the pile of garbage.
Let's take this.
Oh!
He's moving?
Maybe we can take it this way?
Oh, he went... Okay, he just changed channels.
We're good.
From the bath into the trash can.
Wait, I think it's faster if I take it from here.
Yeah.
It'll be great if I can stop spinning.
at the very least it's making me so motion sick oh no look
at you my camera's just going woo woo
70k let's go let's go oh oh oh oh oh oh thank you i was so
close i was so close yes yes you can do it how do i get you
how do i get you oh there we go i need timey yeah yeah thank
you thank you so
you guys thank you so much did you get flushed outside oh
there he is i got flushed the music means he's coming i'm
gonna i'm gonna oh we can we can come fast travel if you
want yeah that's what i was about to do i don't know where
we end up whoa whoa whoa whoa what is that hi what is that
hello oh oh can we fast travel straight to you phoebe it's
fate yeah
Wait, what just happened?
What was it?
What does it do?
I don't know.
How mysterious.
We could steal the Roomba.
I like the Roomba.
What's he got in his closet?
Nothing.
This guy has nothing.
Oh, I died.
You died?
Oh, I'm in the Roomba.
I'm in the Roomba.
Oh, no.
Wait, I'll untie you.
In the Roomba.
I untied you, but does it let you leave?
Oh, and it says I could get there.
someone to help me but wait i did i did though no baby can
we can we lift it up can we move it oh baby a button on top
they said button on top oh
oh yeah thank you thank you oh no problem he's got let's uh
some stuff up here like some makeup stuff I guess this, I
don't know.
For days where he wants to feel kind of pretty.
Yeah.
Was there anything in his wardrobe?
No.
He had nothing.
You know, for a burglary thing, this guy does not have a lot
of stuff for us to burgl.
Right.
Oh, um, a little problem.
Oh, don't worry, I'm fine.
Oh, you did?
I walked into the trap, but now I'm fine.
Oh, he's watching TV, so he's kind of like right in front of
where we need to go.
Unfortunately.
Unless we leave out.
Can we, like, turn off the TV?
I don't think we can, though, right?
I could throw the ball.
Distract him.
No!
Let me go!
Where's he taking you to?
Out the window.
That's probably the best place for me to go, to be honest.
Okay.
Oh, there's something.
There's some cheese or something up there.
All right.
Meh.
Oh my gosh.
Five minutes left.
Baby run!
I'm trying.
What was that?
Someone's...
Where did he take you?
Not the microwave.
Not the microwave!
Wait.
I can bring this stuff out here.
Wait, what the heck is this?
There's another person.
Oh, they took my thing.
They took my burgled.
They took my...
They're helping you.
Okay.
I'll get you from the microwave nice thank you oh there's a
fairy you don't have what lizzie wants oh my god how do I
get to you wait I don't think I can get to you um it's okay
just just get as much stuff as you can no Phoebe no no we
can we can uh uh Vicky where are you oh yeah I'm near the
front door here let's uh let's Let's grab the...
I'll take this nail varnish, yeah.
Oh, it is warm.
Wait, I need your help, I think, once you're done, to, uh...
Please take the nail stuff, because that is what I was
trying to protect.
Yes, don't worry, I'll take it for you.
Once you're...
Oh.
Who is this random helper?
Thank you.
Thank you, bro.
I'm coming, Phoebe!
I'm coming!
Where are you guys?
I'm going back to the kitchen.
Yeah, yeah, come here.
Come help me with this.
Okay.
Where are we taking it?
To feed me.
Oh, watch out.
He's walking.
Towards us?
Be careful.
He's coming around the corner.
Okay, we're good.
We're good.
Yeah, you're good.
He's not hungry.
Wait, can we steal his bread?
Did he just go outside?
I don't know.
Oh, oh!
He's not with Zuka.
Be careful.
I'll take that.
I'll...
He doesn't know.
He's walking around.
He doesn't know where we are.
Oh no!
It's still not tall enough.
I think I have to pull one of the drawers out.
Oh, okay.
Yeah.
Oh, oops.
Oh, I'm dead.
No, don't, don't leave me.
I got, I got cooked just now.
No!
We were just right here!
We just made it!
No!
I won't let you die like this!
Oh, there's the body!
Oh man!
Well, I can untie you, but it doesn't really help much.
We can revive you.
Yeah.
I'm going to...
And the all-bright chat.
Yeah, yeah.
We could steal the bread.
Yeah, I'm stealing his bread.
I'm stealing his bread.
Take that bread home with me.
Wait, what was that sound?
Oops.
You okay?
Yes.
Oh, your arms.
I took a ride on a cockroach.
Oops.
you're fine probably yes please don't get kidnapped by the
room but oh okay I'm coming what's a bore tusk you don't
have it Lizzie once what does she want yeah Lizzie Lizzie
wants a bore tusk I don't know where we're meant to get that
a bore oh I'm here thank you um I'm dead again what was that
a good thing I ran inside hello thank you what was that I
don't know Oh, that's not a friend.
Task complete.
Oh.
What was that?
Oh, I think I'm slipping on stuff, which I think was a task.
Oh.
I see.
Is there, like, a place to see our tasks, I wonder?
It's a good question.
Uh-oh.
When should we head out?
It said, like, five minutes.
Why is Bro...
Okay.
To be honest, that was...
probably okay i wait guys i i he is now down and so am i oh
you're down i he bazookaed me but in the process i'll get
you i'll get you i'll get you back it's okay don't worry
i've i've given you guys the opportunity also for some
reason he was he was naked he was he was yes oh wait we're
out of charges i don't know why there's a limited amount of
charges on the spirit orb Yeah, we can't bring you back.
No!
Becky!
Wait, can we take the bazooka?
It's okay, guys.
Oh, yeah, try, try, try.
Let's do it.
It's going to look like an interesting, yeah.
Wait, it might be two people.
Just me and the guy and the bazooka.
Wait, where are you anyway?
I don't know.
I walked through quite a lot of the house, I'll be honest.
Oh, wait, there's some cheese.
Oh, I see the bazooka.
Can we take the cheese?
Oh, he is.
Oh, he's like.
Oh, oh, oh, my God.
Get it.
Oh, my God.
Okay, okay.
Out of time, get to the tornado.
Go guys, you can do it.
I'm running.
You did great, guys.
Go, go, go, go, go.
Go, go, go, go, go, go.
Run!
Get that sponge in that, yeah.
Yeah!
Cheese!
Because there might be a...
Well, I'm gonna say cheese.
Yeah.
But there's that guy who beat us up last time, is there too.
I'm going, I'm going, I'm going, I'm going.
Yeah!
No!
Yay!
Money, hopefully!
Yes!
Good job, everyone!
Oh!
Right, surely we did a good job.
Surely the high gnome will praise us this time.
Surely, surely.
Thank you for your help.
When do I come back?
Oh, yeah.
Um, maybe you get spat out by the tree.
Yeah, I guess so.
Let her release her.
Release her.
Right now.
Or release her.
Or release.
Oh, you're going to go.
I'm going to go.
The birth of Vicky.
Time for our verdict, I guess.
Our judgment.
When do we get our verdict?
Right here.
Gather.
Gnome port.
Gather clonk.
What is clonk?
Yeah.
Oh, make a gnome slip.
I did that.
Open cabinet.
We did.
Break the television.
Oh.
Oh, guys.
We did great.
Yeah.
Oh.
When gnome dead.
Oh, maybe he broke the television in the process.
Yes, maybe.
He probably did, right?
Yippee!
Good job, everybody.
We got paid.
Does that mean we can buy some stuff?
We can actually craft some things.
The smacker.
Oh, I got a smacker.
A glider.
Wait, that sounds so fun.
Oh, can't afford.
No!
Spring shoes.
I'm going to make spring shoes, okay?
Yeah.
Can't afford.
Oh, wait.
What?
Oh wait no Oh yeah now it says I can't afford it but I made
spring shoes Oh good good Oh wow Well the spring shoes are
so cool Wait did you get anything Vicky Is there anything to
make?
No I think I think we had shed Shared clonk I believe
There's a blow gun if you want that Shoots blow dart Whoa Or
a slingshot Wait you become a walking slingshot for your
friends wait that's huge too how do we use these items oh no
yeah how do i i don't know how to equip mine oh there it is
oh sorry oh how did you do it uh i pressed one ah shoot me
i'm not feeling anything that does not seem to be doing very
much you're like oh maybe we are immune Yeah, maybe.
I guess so.
Or if it doesn't work.
Do you want to try the slingshot?
Oh, shoots blowdots.
Oh, shoots blowdots made with the repackager.
Oh!
Do I have to make?
What's the repackager?
I don't know.
Equipment.
I don't even see it in here.
Yeah, does it need dots?
Yeah, I guess so.
But I don't actually know how we make those.
Oh, there's different...
Oh, we can go to an island, you guys.
That's so fun.
Let's go!
Yeah!
No.
Oh, there is.
It's under furniture.
The repackager.
Oh, okay.
Oh, it's locked though.
You have to upgrade your home to the second tier.
Oh, great.
Okay.
So I'm just, I'm just, I'm just blowing spit at people.
No!
Here, I'll craft the slingshot.
Okay, wait.
Oh, how do I use it?
Wait, how do I use it?
Aw, Phoebe, you're so bouncy.
Can you try throwing me?
Throw him.
How do I do that?
I have it.
Oh, um...
Oops.
Oh, hold on.
I think what we have to do is we grab onto the slingshot.
Oh.
Yes.
Oh!
Yep!
And then you launch yourself.
Yes.
Oh.
I think you can...
Wait.
could do that anyway though I don't think that's how you use
it I think if you stretch your arms far enough you can do
that anyway oh no whoa no no
I just watched Phoebe fall off and then Vicky fall off and
then I caught on fire how I think we're ready I think we're
ready to go to the island yeah I think so I agree wait let
me check if it's on the island how do we choose island I
just I'm clicking it, so hopefully it is chosen.
Or maybe you need to click on it, Phoebe, if you click on
the well and then go to map.
Map.
And then island.
Okay.
And then let's see what happens, I guess.
Boom.
Boom, boom, boom, boom.
Those are the Mongolian chants, the throat chants.
Oh, yeah.
Woo-wee!
Woo-wee-goe!
I'm a dead old slingshot, go away.
Wow!
Oh wait, this doesn't look like the island!
This looks very nice!
Where are we?
Whoa!
Oh wait, maybe we are on the island!
Oh yeah!
Oh we are!
Oh it's rocky, wow!
Um...
Where are you guys?
Phoebe, Chibi, are you good?
What happened?
Try to... I don't know.
I haven't borne this load.
No!
Guys!
Aw!
I am one with the sea.
Just take me.
How do you get up?
You guys, you can get out.
You can get out.
Okay.
I'm trying.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
Nice.
Okay.
This looks very nice indeed.
Look at this.
There's even a tree house.
Oh, tree houses.
We're just talking about tree houses.
Can we take this?
This is very remote.
Right?
I wonder how you even get here.
Yeah.
Maybe you can only get here by gnome tornado.
Can we take this?
Apparently, no.
Barbecue?
No.
Or maybe there's something on the barbie.
I don't know.
Oh, on the barbie.
On the barbie.
Yeah, do be jumping.
climb up here look oh that's well nice other area over here
too wowzers how's the view really good oh really good oh are
you okay are you okay your legs are kind of healed yes i'm
fine you're slowly you're gonna grow you'll grow back you'll
grow there you go there you go and there's windows right
here awesome yeah where's the window that we go in there's
two actually Oh, oh, oh, you got this?
What am I doing?
Oh, oh.
There's the front door.
Oh.
Oh, guys, we can go to a seaside cabin.
What's going on?
Oh, oh.
Sorry, he...
He was right there.
Is it the same guy?
It is.
He's at his vacation home, I guess.
Oh.
Bro, I was trying to open the window.
Can you leave me be?
Oh, I think he shut it, because I just opened it.
I'm going to try this window over here, actually.
Oh.
Are you alive?
Okay, yeah.
There we go.
Hair.
Okay.
Oh.
Hair.
Guys, I can just keep him here saying hair me if I stay on
the window.
So if you guys go in, did I just keep him here saying hair?
I'm taking some of his food.
I can't take that.
Wait, can I eat that?
He's literally just staring at me going, I got a scrappling.
I don't know what that means.
Oh, never mind.
He managed to get me.
Oh, I thought I was in like the perfect place.
Oh, hi!
No, but there does seem to be a bit of a like thing, though.
If you stay in one place on the window, he just stays there
looking at you.
Let me try and get to the sweet spot again.
I'm going to start putting stuff out of the window.
Like this bread.
Come on.
Yeah.
I'm gonna try and go upstairs, do it like I'm fine.
You think he notices us?
Yeah, I think he knows that we're here.
Well, he definitely knows that I'm here, but I don't think
he knows that you guys are here.
Uh-oh, where's he taking me?
Oh!
Um, he's coming in.
Oh, oh.
Ah!
Oh.
No!
We'll save you?
Thank you.
Please save me.
We're both in here.
Oh.
Oh, wait.
Okay.
Oh, he's coming outside.
He's coming outside.
Wait, how do we get up, though?
Oh, here we go.
Oh, shoot.
Oh, don't get me to.
No, no, no, no!
I'm stuck!
Ow!
No!
It's not worth it, guys.
Uh-oh.
Save yourselves.
Is he gonna put me in the fish?
No.
He's throwing me outside?
He's feeding me to the Roomba?
No.
He's opening the door?
Oh, he just threw me outside.
We're good.
Did he open the door for us?
Yeah, he opened the front door.
Wait, I think actually...
Wait, where is he taking me?
Wait, he didn't throw me outside.
He's taking me...
Where?
Oh, but...
Oh.
Uh.
I think I'm dead.
Oh, where did you go?
He threw me into the ocean.
Oh, hey, that's rude.
Oh, he's right there.
So rude.
Please.
Be, be careful.
Ah!
Are you...
Are you in the water?
What?
I died.
No!
Not the seagulls!
Becky, where are you?
In the microwave.
Yeah.
Okay, hold on.
I'll be right there.
Yeah.
I'm not having a great time, but if you're able to save me,
that'd be great.
Yeah, if you die too, then we can revive both of us at the
thing.
Yeah.
Right?
At the orb, it should get both of us?
Yes.
Wait, are you dead right now, Minto?
Yeah.
Oh, don't worry.
We both fall.
Oh, yeah.
We both are?
Oh, shoot.
Oh.
Oh, I'm going to go to the microwave.
No.
It's okay.
Don't worry.
Yeah, just revive me.
Did you get any stuff?
Nice.
Yeah.
Oh, thank you.
You got, like, a microwave or something, or a toaster, I
think.
a toaster.
I'm gonna go see what's over.
Well, no.
I'm gonna get my bread.
Unless the birds ate it.
Yeah, it seems like you could pick up food.
Yeah.
I don't know what it does.
It gives us super strength or something.
I don't know.
Oh, I lost my items.
That's so sad.
Oh, no.
What?
Oh.
I saw that happen in real time, Phoebe.
Let me.
Give me a second.
I was trying to prove.
Oh, no.
What?
Who's happening?
We might.
We are both in...
Why is he naked?
We are both in the rumble in the front.
Oh, okay.
I got you guys.
My bread was gone.
Wait, is the rumble taking us outside?
Oh.
Oh, hello guys.
Hello.
The rumble is taking us outside.
Uh.
I'm trying to click anything.
Oh my gosh.
Please.
I'm clicking it, but it's not registered.
You think it's a little impressive with your hair.
Surely three of us can't fit in the rumble, right?
Surely.
Oh my god, please.
The full Minto in the room, but no, don't say that.
It won't turn off.
Oh, there it goes.
Yay!
We're free!
Oh, I wish we could take this guy.
You could see to the evil.
I know, right?
Rumbos are cute.
Where is he?
Is he upstairs?
Downstairs?
We don't know.
I'm checking downstairs.
He's so naked.
He might be upstairs.
Oh, there's more stuff in the kitchen if we want to take,
like, some of these, uh, easy items.
Oh, that might be good.
I was like throwing in the pots down and stuff.
Oh, he's upstairs.
Oh, should we not be coming?
Okay, we're going down again.
Don't go down again.
Okay.
Uh-oh.
Don't get me.
I have a guard.
I have a bodyguard.
I think he's distracted upstairs, actually.
I think we're okay for now.
Wait.
Oh, a blender.
Nice.
Come here.
Come on.
Please help me.
Oh, no.
Mr. Chameleon.
Thank you.
Oh, ow, ow.
I tried to, um...
Yeah, how did it turn into a hotline?
Oh, yeah?
Bro, why have you caught your...
Why is he...
Oh, the door is shut.
I can't open.
Ash!
Oh, no.
I got it.
Oh, he might be...
Oh, no, he's...
Oh, okay, he's put me...
He's put me to have a bath again, it seems like.
Oh, you see, he's also got a gun now?
Oh, yes.
It seems like that is the way.
That is what's happening.
I think Phoebe might have been had some situation with the
blender.
I did.
Are you good, Phoebe?
He's walking around.
Is it?
Oh, no.
No!
I'm okay.
Okay.
Why does it sound like a Minecraft villager?
Oh, he's got you.
He's got you.
He's so naked.
Ew.
Oh, no.
Why is he naked?
You taking a boff, too?
No, where are you going?
Is there a way to...
get up there?
Okay, hold on.
Why did he just look at the room?
He's stuck.
Ew.
Oh, he's stuck.
He's just waiting, man.
Ew, he wants us to view or something.
Yada.
Oh, he's frozen.
Yeah, just do your thing, I guess.
Wait, I don't want to do my thing.
I don't want to see his either.
How do I get up there?
Um, I need something.
who remembered to check the pixelation mode i know right oh
my gosh imagine what what this was is that a mine oh no
there's five minutes left wait don't get me please i mean
this is quite good in terms of gameplay that he's just
standing i feel bad for yeah yeah okay i'm building a my
point of view is so funny i'm just like i'm just like in the
in the fish tank just like watching him standing there
holding okay i got you i got you thank you thank you so much
there we go yay thank you why is he just there why is he
just standing there i can get out i can get out i can't i
can't i definitely can't i'm strong enough for this i can do
it i can do it why can i not get out of here i believe in
you i believe you got this Come on, come on, come on.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, your arms out.
Oh, okay, maybe not.
I feel like it was way easier before to get out of it.
I think I might have glitched out.
No.
Yeah, I...
Guys, I, um...
I don't think this is working.
No, there's no way.
There's no way.
I think it might be all up to you, Minto.
What?
It might all be up to you.
I think we're...
If only I still had my bat.
No, don't give up Vicky to Vicky.
Oh, I made it!
Oh, yeah!
Excuse me.
I, like, went under...
Pardon me.
I went under his foot and he, like, moved it out of the way,
but, like, didn't do anything else.
This is great.
We can just make endless money.
Okay, right.
Yeah.
Let me grab more items.
Phoebe, are you good there, though?
I feel bad.
I know, right?
You know, I think this is a, this is a, this is benefits the
entire team.
Thank you, thank you, thank you so much, Phoebe.
Yeah, I think that's a good idea.
Yeah, yeah, I'm gonna like...
I tried to take his gun.
Oh, oh, I'm okay.
Oh?
You're, you're okay, but watch out for the rumble.
Yeah.
It's alive again.
All right, we got a ball.
Is there anything more worth more money upstairs?
Come on, there's got to be something...
expensive looking or that's an expensive looking candlestick
have a look in there yeah all right we got a ball i'll just
throw everything down let's see what else we got oh watch
out for the door trap what can i see from here the sea what
a beautiful ocean i don't think i can get the expensive
candlestick i tried no i look so expensive though i could
take a slipper oh yeah he'll never have warm feet again
maybe just one warm foot i mean i don't think he seems to be
too bothered about being you know right having his slippers
or any clothing for that matter right i mean he's in his own
home we're the ones invading so i guess yeah that's true why
can't i pick anything up okay oh wrong hand that's why okay
ah let me climb it where are you vicky I'm in the bedroom
still trying to get an item to bring back so I'm not coming
back empty-handed for the team you know all right let's take
this can I take his pillow I wonder where the fast can you
fast travel with an item no you can't oh you can't no oh
that's a shame oh shoot I'm okay what happened fish I lost
my legs I'm fine no I'm okay I'm gonna take his I'm taking
his plant.
It's really nice, actually.
He's still just standing there.
What the heck?
Yeah.
This is great, though.
Just endless money.
Oh, nice.
Nice.
Thank you.
Where's the front door?
Like, the way it's spinning.
It's spinning around.
It doesn't show you as dead, Phoebe.
Or, like...
I'm not.
I saw that.
I can't spectate, but I am watching the stream.
Oh, I'm sorry.
Oh, no.
Okay.
I mean, honestly, great day's known work today.
Yeah.
Very, very lucrative.
Very lucrative.
Very lucrative indeed.
I think I'll hit the unstuck button as soon as you guys are
ready to, like, go.
I think we're ready.
We've got plenty of stuff, haven't we?
See what happens.
I'm intrigued to see what happens.
I'm going to watch it happen.
Are you guys safely out of the house?
Uh, no, I'm right in front of you, but I want to see what
happens, so it's fine.
Oh, oh, here we go.
Get to the tornado!
Oh, oh, oh, okay.
Go, go, go!
He's so confused!
Go, go!
He's confused?
Is he walking still?
Go, go, go, go, go!
He is raising and lowering his gun over and over.
Oh, no!
Yoi!
job guys I feel bad this guy has no stuff in his house I
feel like he's burgled often I mean think of all the people
playing this game we're constantly burglary I know they're
taking his things all the time no wonder he's got guns and
bazookas yeah he's sick of it you know there's not he
doesn't have much stuff in the house I think he could do
with like I don't know I think he could do with like some
MVP merch personally yeah yeah
Welcome back.
That was fun.
Yeah.
Here's our report.
Oh, how did we do?
Seal account, too.
What was that?
Travel through the sewer system.
There's a sewer system.
Oh.
Wait.
What?
We still make it, though, right?
We've got so much stuff.
Oh, come on.
What?
Okay, so is this?
Is there a way to check objectives?
Yeah, I couldn't find a way.
I was trying to check.
That is rude.
How are we supposed to know what the objectives are?
Are we just supposed to do as much stuff as possible?
Huh?
Tab?
Oh.
We had a whole heckin' thing.
Well, that's fine.
We did good, guys.
I mean, we, you know, no matter what the high gnome says, we
did great.
We're great gnomes.
Yeah, we stole.
I thought the idea was to steal a bunch of stuff, not...
Yeah, it's literally called burglaring gnomes.
Yeah!
And we burgled a lot, I think.
We did.
Yeah.
Aw, fun game, guys.
Yeah, quite fun.
It was quite chaotic and MVP coded, actually.
Maybe a little bit, yeah.
Yeah, I'm glad I got to experience life things.
Life and hugs.
Hugs.
Aw.
That's so cute.
Smooch.
So wiggly.
I like this guy.
He's so helpful.
Yeah, I like this.
I like him too!
Yeah!
Hug, hug, hug, hug, hug.
Thank you very much.
Thank you, Michikami.
I hope that you have a safe child birth.
Um, I might be on...
Okay.
No, Vicky!
Vicky, no!
You have to come back and see the buttocks of this guy too.
It's very...
The what?
Oh, the buttocks?
Oh, really?
Yeah, come check.
Oh, that is very interesting.
That piques my interest.
That's like...
Give me a second.
I'm on my way.
On my way.
Yeah.
Oh, wow.
That is some cake and a half.
Wow.
Yeah.
Just slap that.
Okay, anyway, guys, that was burgling gnomes.
That was burgling gnomes.
Yay!
Fun time, fun time.
It has been the turn of the hour, so as much fun as we've
been...
Oh, did you just fall?
You?
As much fun as we've been having.
It's time for our $1,000 goal activity.
Yay!
Alrighty.
Out of character script reading!
Woohoo!
Alrighty.
Give me a second.
Yeah, I was gonna say, can we have a quick like, quick, uh,
go get water for like a couple of minutes.
Yeah, yeah.
Before we transition into the next section.
Alright.
gonna go grab some water yes I'll see you guys in a little
bit mm-hmm all right see you guys in a little bit quick be
right back and then we'll be back with our next corner very
shortly yeah
we're back we're back we're back we're back oh and and what
is this fantastical wheel whoa we are on to our segment of
what how would we call this what it would out of character
voice acting out of character voice acting script reading oh
but first before we go into the next segment let's take a
little moment to talk a little bit again about uh hope for
the day that we are fundraising for today so thanks to you
guys we are on an incredible 72 000 dollars wow um and you
know thinking about what that money will do so a thousand
dollars um expands the stream for hope program to reach
thousands more online 500 equips one school with resources
and training.
Wait, that means that that's like 140 schools.
Right!
That's crazy!
How many of you guys?
Wow!
The masks, the masks, quick masks, they're feeding us.
I know, wow.
$200 funds a community education workshop, free for all
participants, and $25 prints and distributes 100 mental
health resource cards.
So think of all of the stuff that hopefully they can do with
the money that you guys have fundraised.
That is awesome!
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
Does one of you want to explain a little bit more about what
Hope for the Day does?
Hope for the Day is a non-profit that, like, empowers people
and educates them about mental health.
It fundraisers for it.
It helps provide people with resources and the courage to
reach out to these resources.
It, like, it's for everyday people.
It's not just benefiting clinicians, but it equips everyday
people to respond and recognize and connect others to care.
The kind of care that they need to take care of them.
Their hearts and their minds.
So thank you, everybody, for your very generous donations on
going towards a good cause.
And, you know, if you ever need help, you know, if you're
ever finding yourself feeling a little.
a little emotionally wavy, you know, and needing a little
extra boost.
Programs like Hope for the Day.
They are around also to kind of, they have resources as well
online for, if you need to talk to somebody.
So, it's very important.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
But we have some fun scripts now for this.
Oh, scripts.
Yeah.
Which ones do we want to go from, I wonder?
We have several different types of scripts for you guys
today.
Which corner do we want to start with, I guess.
Well, I guess we'll kind of explain what we are doing,
right?
So, as you can see, we have this funny, funny wheel going
on.
And Phoebe and Vicky, for the most, I didn't have so much
time, but they provided so many lines from all over, from, I
guess, like, movies and games and memes and everything and
we will spin the wheel and each of us has to voice act said
said uh script to the best of our ability doing the prompt
that falls upon us on the the magic wheel so yes yes which
if it's multiple characters maybe we'll do like you know
pick the two people to do it and then spin twice as well so
each plus is doing a different one i think would yeah it's
almost like choicer voicer but just this yeah yeah exciting
if you guys um want to send i guess we could like go like i
don't know phoebe vicky and you guys like pick one from your
lists and copy and paste and like then i'll include it on
here sure so then i can just grab it from you guys yeah all
right phoebe which one do you want to start with um Um, do
you want me to paste it in the group chat?
Yeah, yeah.
Okay.
Alrighty.
Oh my god.
Oh, sorry.
Did you want me to put just a title or the whole thing?
No, no.
I think the whole thing.
We'll just, we'll just.
Yeah.
Well, I'll, um.
I'm so excited for who I was going to do this one.
Oh, wait.
How do we, do we each do it or are we going to, how do we
want to do it?
do we at least one of us but if we want to do it if we like
it enough and want to do another one so this one is the one
i chose ken sama ken sama oh my god wow wow ken sama i guess
it should be like someone other than the person who chose
the script maybe oh yeah maybe right okay who do you reading
this one yeah Phoebe you can decide okay I have I have I
have a follow-up to Ken Sama so I have people in mind for
each this one is going to be Minto okay go on Ken Sama okay
but what voice will it be what voice will it be oh no okay
um sorry if you guys can't I tried to as easily as possible
but um yeah okay
they're gonna be what's it gonna be what's it gonna be you
can change
it to a 67 year old no 67 years young here i'll turn off the
music for this Alrighty, so this is Ken-sama as done by
grandpa.
Okay, oh, here I'll give myself the mic one moment.
There we go, okay.
Gomenesai, my name is Ken-sama.
I am a 27-year-old American otaku, anime fan for you guy
jeans.
I draw anime and manga on my tablet and spend my day
perfecting my art and playing superior Japanese games a la
disgea and final fantasy and persona series.
I train with my katana every day.
weapon can cut glean through steel because it is folded over
a thousand times and is vastly superior to any other weapon
on earth.
I earned my sword license two years ago and I've been
getting better every day.
Wow.
Whoa.
I speak Japanese fluently.
Both kanji and the Osaka dialect.
And I write fluently as well.
I know everything about Japanese history and their Bushido
code, which I follow 100%.
Ooh, sagoising.
Oh, I'm sorry.
When I get my Japanese visa, I am moving to...
Who wrote Japanese and not Nipponjin?
Nipponjin.
I am moving to Tokyo to attend a prestigious high school to
learn more about their magnificent culture.
He's tough.
I hope I can become an animator for studio Djibouti or a
game designer in my youth.
Oh, no, I just saw it like another line.
I own several kimono which I wear around town.
I want to get used to wearing them before I move to Nippon,
so I can fit in easier.
I bow to my elders, which is not many left.
I bow to my elders and seniors and speak Japanese as often
as I can.
But rarely does anyone manage to respond.
Wish me luck in Japan.
buddy my show
man i love i love ken shama amazing 11 out of 10 oh my god
thank you thank you subarashi subarashi truly subarashi
thank you thank you y'all bye oh incredible everybody say
gambare ken shama in the comments gambare ken shama say febi
did you write this or did you get this from somewhere Yeah,
this is a coffee pasta.
Oh, I mean, I would have believed it if you said you'd wrote
written it as well.
However, there is a follow-up.
There is a follow-up we can do later on.
There is.
Oh, nice.
I mean, we can do it now if you want to.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, okay.
This one's for Vicky next.
Oh, thank you so much.
Who is going to be the next character?
Oh, let's check it out.
Oh.
Next up we've got...
Oh,
heck yeah.
This is made for me, it's made for me, guys.
What is it?
It's value, it's value!
I want space!
Oh, my gosh.
Okay, guys, are you ready?
Literally, yeah.
We are the script up, Minto, and I'm so ready to go.
Oh, my gosh.
What's up?
You guys, literally right before stream, I said that I put
on Valley Girl for Vicky.
So this is absolutely perfect.
Daisy May is ready to read this, guys.
Okay, all right.
Howdy.
My name is Rohide Kobayashi.
I'm a 27-year-old Japanese, Japanese-American, Western
culture fan for you foreigners.
I brand and wrangled cattle on my ranch and spend my days
perfecting the craft and enjoying superior American pastimes
like barbecue, rodeos, and fireworks.
I train with my branding iron every day.
This superior weapon can permanently leave my wrench
emboldened on a cattle's hide because it is white hot and it
is vastly superior to any other method of livestock marking.
I earned my branding license two years ago.
I've been getting better every day.
Wow.
I speak American fluently, both Texas and Oklahoma dialect,
and I write fluently as well.
I know everything about American history and their cowboy
coats, which I follow 100%.
When I get my American visa, I am moving to Dallas to work
in an oil field to learn more about their magnificent
culture.
I hope I can become a cattle wrangler for the double cross
ranch or an oil rig operator for Exxon Mobil.
I own several cowboy hats, guys, several, which I wear
around town.
I want to get used to wearing them before I move to America
so I can fit in easier.
I rebel against my elders and seniors and speak English as
often as I can.
But rarely does anyone manage to respond.
Wish me luck in America, guys.
Bye, Slay!
Slay!
Wish you luck, Daisy Ray!
Thanks, guys.
So do I get my American visa?
Is that how yeah?
Oh, you guys.
You're a citizen now.
Yeah, perfect.
Okay, cool.
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
I didn't realize how it was like like when they were talking
about the branding iron, I was like, what is this?
I didn't realize it was like one for one just like the same
copy pasta.
I was like, oh my god, and then I was like, oh no, this is
our, this is the American weapon.
This is the American thousand folded katana.
I enjoy, I rebel against my elder seeds and speak English as
often as I can.
It's so funny.
What?
Oh, that was amazing.
Yeah.
All right.
Vicky, do you have one that you would like to?
Oh, I do.
I'd like one.
have one that I'd like you guys to do together, actually.
Yeah.
Together.
Yeah, together.
I think I think you should spin the wheel for like each of
them, you know, and just... Oh my God.
Okay.
Oh, no, okay.
Alrighty.
I think you guys should do different ones.
If you have role assignments in mind.
Oh, I think I would like Mint to be Edward.
Okay.
And I would like Phoebe to be Bella.
Okay, okay.
Sorry, I'm like trying to do this.
There we go.
That should be a little bit better.
Sorry, guys.
You can't see the full thing, but.
Okay, so I will roll for you, Phoebe.
This could be really bad, depending on what we get.
Oh.
Wait, this is so perfect for you.
Animal Crossing.
Oh!
Ah!
Perfect.
We have Phoebe playing Bella Swan as done by Animal Crossing
Voice and myself, Edward.
I almost said Edward Elric.
What's his name?
Edward Cullen.
As...
Duh-uh-uh-uh-uh-uh-uh-uh-uh-uh-uh-uh-uh-uh.
Mickey!
Yay!
Okay!
all righty um we could start whenever you're right to calm
myself okay all right i'm ready i'm so ready okay okay okay
deep breath real quick yeah okay say
it out loud say it
are you afraid then ask me the most basic question ha ha
He takes her arm.
He takes her arm and leads her walking fast.
Out the mountain, ha-ha.
Out of the cloud bank.
You need to know what I look like in the sunlight.
They fly, sort of.
This is why I don't show ourselves.
Oh, wait.
This is why we don't show ourselves in the sunlight.
People wouldn't know that we're different.
This.
is what i am edward walks into a sunbeam and he sparkles
beautiful this is the skin of a killer bella i'm a killer
that is that is everything i've ever dreamed of and more
that was so wonderful you guys i think you deserve an oscar
you both do that this wheel is so it's so faded it is it is
the wheel of fate wow incredible stuff oh my gosh wait what
are we what are we doing next guys um do you want to do
another one vicky since febe did too sure yeah um
do this one you can assign you can assign roles however you
want um i'm happy to be any any we have to all do this one
i'm happy to be any any of the roles oh my gosh oh oh okay
okay
oh no wait i don't know how we have i don't remember what
you how each one sounds okay we have three roles we have uh
we have koneko chan we have rakuchan and we have hitoshi I
kind of want chat to assign us the characters here.
Oh, okay chat.
Yeah.
Let's see.
I'd love to try Raku-chan.
Raku-chan.
Yeah, I'll just put Raku-chan.
What was it, Koneko-chan?
Koneko-chan.
Yeah, sorry.
No, it's okay.
I just wrote the letters.
I'll just for each.
Oh, Hitoshi-san.
I kind of want to try Hitoshi-san.
Oh, yeah.
But...
What is chat, Jake?
Yeah.
You mean Hitoshi-san?
Takashi?
I could, well, you wanted to be Raku-chan, Vicky?
Oh, it's okay.
It's okay.
I think, I mean, I do agree that maybe me as Koneku-chan
makes sense, but I can do either.
I think all of them are fine.
Hmm.
Oh, mint Koneku.
Okay.
Whatever, whatever, really.
I'll be Koneku.
I mean, I quite fancy doing the stream, the screaming.
No.
I need to get in the zone.
Okay, okay, okay.
All right.
Oh, yeah, there is the screaming.
Okay, great, great.
Shall we?
Let's do that.
Shall we spin?
All right, first for Phoebe.
Whatever could it be?
It is.
I'm so sorry.
Yay!
My stream is catching up.
It's Frogbert.
Frogbert.
Do you know how to...
Frog butt?
Here, this is how...
So basically frog bird just sounds kind of similar to like a
certain green frog that...
Just do Kermit.
I see.
I...
Hold on.
I've never done a Kermit voice before.
I've done Mickey.
This is how...
This is our voice acting training.
Kermitly frog here.
Kermitly frog.
Okay.
I'm going to do my best.
All right.
For Vicky.
I mean, legally, legally distinct frog.
Legally distinct frog.
What's it gonna be, what's it gonna be?
No, no, it's Valley Girl again.
Spin again, spin again, spin again.
Anything you do, we can spin again, yeah, yeah.
Okay, okay.
Just- It's Valley Girl.
It knows, it knows, it's literally rigged in a good way.
It's Valley Girl again.
It is close enough.
Baby voice.
I mean, that kind of works.
It actually works.
It's just basically trying to do it like the original.
Okay, and then Koneko-chan.
Koneko-chan.
It is.
Oh.
Silly accent.
Okay.
I didn't put like British accent and well okay I'll do my
best British accent you could be a very British Koneko Chan
yes I will very British Koneko Chan all right all right okay
are we in the zone guys we in the zone everybody please
enjoy the Den Setsu Daexi rendition of can I can I sing the
song here just to make just to get the immersion yes yes do
do do do do do do do do do do do okay all right
it's very sunny wait what's how do i do a british accent
again it's very sunny outside today oh i think i'm gonna go
outside today kawaii squirrel chan oh so desu ni oh so ni
kawaii squeakus chan you so desu and sugoi oh so soft oh oh
hi toshi i really hope he's doing all right after the whole
kidnapping incident everything.
Hitoshi said, I hope we can come this so just the three of
us near...
Walking to the store.
Lola, lola, lola, lola, lola.
Oh, hello there, Hitoshi said.
How are you doing today?
Well, well...
Well, hello there, Koneko.
How do I do this?
Well, help.
Help.
Come on.
Permit me, the fall.
I can't.
Hello there.
Hello there, Koneko-chan.
You are looking very nice today and I am doing fine.
Thank you very much.
Well, I just wanted to tell you that, you know, Raku-chan,
thanks that you're really sugoi-nyah.
Oh, well, oh, well, tell her I say thank you very much, nya,
and that I appreciate her kindness.
Hey, Toshi-san, are you all right, Rav?
wasn't he like fantasizing about his boyfriend here or
something oh i'm fine don't worry about me one bit well i
better tell rakuchan that i think she's a really cool neko
and that she's a pretty downright sugoi oh yeah raku-chan
are you home hey
toshin i'm really
waku-chan we brought you a present to make you feel better
yeah rar wait that just sounded like him
get well soon raku-chan
singing sushi.
Oh, Koneko-chan, Hitoshi says, you do so much for me.
I don't even know if I deserve it.
Thank you so much.
Arigato, meow.
Oh, I feel so much better, meow.
Thank you for your help, meow.
Don't thank us.
It was our pleasure, Raku-chan.
Oh, you guys, that soon.
I really wish
I think my favorite was Kuneika Chen and be like, you're
right, bro.
He talks to you, you're right, bro.
Thank goodness.
Okay, I made it.
We made it.
right good job team how are we feeling i think i'm good to
move on to the mad libs if you guys are unless there was any
other do you do any of the particular scripts you really
wanted to do febe for this section if you do then let's do
those we did the we did the best ones honestly yeah i think
i did the best ones of mine too okay and yeah the mad libs
all right for the mad libs is yours structured in a similar
way febe that we give you words or is it different oh well i
remember i ended up writing one that was not appropriate for
stream oh i didn't have i didn't have time to rewrite oh no
problem okay guys it's fine i think i think mine actually we
could probably like even reuse them uh once each two so
don't worry okay what i need from you first you guys so have
a little thing um i would like for script one two verbs
everybody's confused What do you mean?
Because Phoebe was like I wrote something that wasn't
appropriate.
Oh, I see.
Release the Phoebe script.
Well, maybe we could do it on another stream.
How about that?
On another one.
Yeah, yeah.
So I'll keep it a surprise.
But for the sake of this one.
Yeah.
It had a lot of cussing in it, guys.
It had a lot of cussing.
Yeah.
Okay guys, I want each of you right now!
To think of...
Actually let's do, mmm...
How many...
Do you want to run through the same script twice?
Or how about...
No, how about we do each script once?
Let's do that and then I'll get you guys to do one time each
thinking of the words.
Okay, who would like to start with thinking of the words?
Mint or Phoebe?
Oh.
Wait, but then, do you have one to do, Vicky?
I'm...
I've got roles in the script.
Oh, okay okay, okay, okay.
We've all got roles.
We've all got roles in both.
Oh, I see!
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay.
Let's start with Minto.
Okay, what do you mean?
Give me two verbs, please.
Two verbs.
Oh, I saw someone in the chat.
Squishing.
Okay.
Give me three adjectives.
Oh wait, should they be ING verbs or?
I don't know, that's good.
That's good.
Yeah, ING is good.
Give me three adjectives.
Smelly.
Stinky.
Yes.
Uh.
Hmm.
Oh, gosh.
These are hard.
I haven't done Mad Libs in so long.
Moe.
Go free to take inspiration.
from chat.
Moe.
Give me two body parts.
Appropriate body parts, please.
Pinky toe.
Yep.
And flesh fang.
Flesh fang.
Okay.
Give me five objects.
An object.
Oh.
Hmm.
Just anything.
Anything.
Literally anything.
Five objects.
Okay.
Phoebe's hair.
Yep.
Michael.
The more random the better.
Okay, okay.
Just any object lying around.
Oh, okay.
Let's look at my...
My naked Ryden nenderoid.
Okay.
How do you spell Ryden?
R-A-I-D-E-N?
Yeah, yeah, naked.
Yeah, yeah, Ryden, yeah.
Okay.
How many is that?
That's three.
We need two more.
Okay, okay.
Um.
I feel like this is going to be good.
Yeah.
Um.
Feel free to take inspiration from chat.
Yeah, I'm trying to look.
Come on.
Uh, I'm, uh, let's see.
Um.
Guys, help, help.
Oh, um...
Idol checky.
Idol checky, yeah.
One more object.
Dojinchi.
Okay.
And give me two people.
Give me anyone, you know, like...
Solid snake, or, I don't know, whatever you want.
Solid snake and shadow the hedgehog.
Okay.
And give me two creatures.
Creators.
Mm-hmm.
Oh, um, oh my gosh.
It can be animal.
Yeah.
Reptile.
Mothman.
Anything or anything?
Minotaur.
I hope I spelled that right.
One vehicle.
Tricycle.
I don't know.
Okay.
One place.
Can be anything.
Can be like a building.
Can be a...
country can be a town whatever you want really oh oh oh
place uh yeah we'll do akiba apart from akiba oh because
that ruins the point so far from akiba okay all right um oh
what's a place um your mom's basement
I meant one, one name, a name that you might call something,
just a, you know, Bob.
Oh, one name.
Evan, anything.
Uh, bloopy.
Bloopy.
Right, you guys chat amongst yourselves while I quickly copy
paste these into the script for you.
Okay, I'm excited.
I'm very, very excited.
Something about Akiba already, you guys.
Hmm.
Yeah, that's all you know so much.
far vicky's mom's basement okay oh is it specifically
vicky's mom okay i'll amend it oh it can be your mom yeah
just you could say your mom it's okay yeah okay guys so just
give me a second while i put everything in here i should
have done loitering as one of the verbs oh no do you want to
change it no no it's okay it's okay okay i'm i'm scared what
the is all about um oh no i'm gonna go with vicky's mom's
baby okay
yes it's gonna take me a couple minutes so uh feel free to
yeah feel free to explode everybody too or use explode next
time yeah yeah oh i'll use my uh i'm gonna use my laser beam
eyeballs to explode different members of chat.
Yeah.
Are we doing the wheel for this one?
No.
Because we are in it and then there are three other
characters that will soon appear.
Okay.
Wow, you created a whole MCU.
Let's go.
Yeah, guys, there's a whole heckin universe.
Okay.
Oh, Penguin, you want to be exploded.
Pew pew.
Get lasered.
you sorry i'm sorry i keep laughing at this okay guys you
will see it very shortly i'm excited i'm so excited you're
ready for the phoebe beam zelda stuck pew pew pew pew pew um
okay i'm nearly there i'm so nearly there guys it's getting
there give me give me my minutes
challenge shiver pew pew yeah laser them all laser them yeah
yeah thank you vicky's mom for her contribution yeah of the
basement my parents do actually have a basement so it's kind
of accurate it's perfect it's perfect it's heckin scary in
there oh i'm just like somebody called you a stormtrooper
yeah dude i got better aim than a stormtrooper oh my gosh uh
i need to scroll Oh yeah, stormtroopers are sexy.
85 Rommels, pew pew!
Oh yeah.
It's nearly that, it's nearly that, guys.
It's cooking, it's cooking.
It's cooking, guys.
Let's go.
My...
Oh boy.
Minto?
Yeah.
Do you need anything laser?
everybody in chat oh everyone in chat everybody in chat you
cannot wait uh summon the omega phoebe laser beam you guys
are toast
oh no oh no
okay guys the script is in yay oh too bad no one's here to
listen to the script anymore.
They all got lasered.
I know.
Everybody is just... Everybody is French toast.
They've turned French, too.
Wait, what?
Is that what happens?
Yeah.
Okay, the script is ready.
Okay!
It's in the chat.
Okay.
Oh, boy.
Oh, wow.
It's okay.
Are there certain people who are going to be voicing those?
Um, I think it'll be natural.
Ah, I think I think I see Mint as character one, me as
character two, and Phoebe as character three, I think.
Okay.
Uh, I, anyone can do the narration.
Who wants to do the narration?
Anyone wanting to have a crack at the narration?
Okay, let's go.
Yeah, okay.
Ready?
Yes.
Mm.
Vicky was roaring in the streets of Akihabara when she heard
a big roar.
Wow!
What a smelly roar!
I have to warn the others about this.
But there was no need, as Mint already had to stop all her
squishing in the maid cafe.
Phoebe's hair fell over!
What is going on?
For Phoebe, she was all the way in Vicky's pretty mom's
basement.
But she headed there straight away on getting Vicky's text.
Oh, a huge mothman kaiju!
I've heard of this guy in the history books.
They call it... bloopy.
Don't worry, guys.
I came prepared.
I have exactly what we need to protect ourselves.
She opens her bag and brings out three items.
Mint.
Oh, oh, oh.
Oh, sorry, I didn't write my name, but I think I meant to
say this.
Mint, take this magical Michael.
Yeah!
TB, take this naked rider nendroid of protection.
As for me, I will take the shield of idle checkies.
Yeah!
Unfortunately, none seem to be very effective.
They thought all hope was lost when who would appear on
their left side, but solid snake go for it minto it is i
solid snake here to save the day with my with my with my
stinky with
my stinky sidekick minotaur at my side anything is possible
on the right side shadow the turns up.
On a tr- On a tr- On a tr- Hey, sickle.
Um, Shadow the Hedgehog.
Well, hello there, ladies.
Don't couch Shadow the Hedgehog out of the equation.
I'll use-
I'll use my moe at Pinky Toe to tame this beast.
With all five of them surrounding the Mothman, they shrunk
back to their normal size and began to speak.
Oh!
You can be mothmaned, Phoebe.
I cannot thank you enough for allowing me to see the error
in my ways.
Here, a rare dojin-shi as a token of my appreciation.
Everyone raised their flesh bang in the air as they jumped
for joy.
And Akiba was safe once again.
it's canon for real yeah totally canon guys canon mvp story
this is this is how we save akiba thank you thank you for
the ring hello hope you guys had a good stream yeah beanie
bugs and bug bros and bro beanie bros everybody beanie bros
yeah thanks for the rain Alright, that was...
Just take a breather.
That was great.
Can you guys, are you guys okay to do another one?
Do you think you can cope with another one?
Yes.
Yes, okay.
All right.
Phoebe, you'll go this time.
Yeah.
Give me one adjective.
Oh, um...
Uh...
Booty-licious.
Mmm.
Great.
Give me two adverbs.
Adverbs, you probably already know what an adverb is.
But it's like, cute-ly or something, yeah.
Uh, let's see.
Uh,
spitefully?
Spitefully.
And then...
Uh...
Daintily.
Give me one.
one verb oh um
uh let's see to shimmy shimmy i'm gonna check on my cat
that's a good verb oh yeah yeah yeah two people please so
again can be anyone you like like the last story um let's
see are there question real quick are there creatures in
this one as well are you gonna ask Yes, I am going to ask
you for creatures, yes.
Okay, then I will not list a creature as a person.
Okay, two people.
Yes.
You can give me creatures first, if you want.
You've got those first.
Oh, well, snake and shadow were in it, so can I put Fujikaze
as one of them?
Fujikaze, yeah.
Yes, and then the other one will be Steiner.
Okay.
And then one place, please.
So it could be a country, a town, or...
Could you say, in my heart?
Aww.
Maybe not that.
I feel like a place is better.
I feel like a place, like an actual place is better.
I think that's more funny, yeah.
Let's see.
Let's do...
I'm Donut Ikebukuro.
I'm Donut!
Oh, wow.
Oh, yeah.
That's a good place.
Okay, yeah, yeah.
Okay.
Can you give me one liquid, please?
Oh, sorry, no, you didn't give me creatures yet.
Two creatures, please.
Two creatures, Squonk.
How do you spell Squonk?
S-Q-U-O-N-K.
Okay, yep.
And then Fresno Nightcrawler.
Yeah, oh my gosh, I almost said that one, but I was like,
maybe I shouldn't say it just in case.
Fresno, I-F-R-E-S-N-O.
Yes.
Nightcrawler, okay.
Pants.
one liquid please oh oh uh elmer's glue oh elmer's glue oh
or just glue in general probably glue okay um can you give
me one food please oh um sausage okay yummy i'm gonna snack
on some cheeses can you give me one object please oh Oh,
yes.
The orb.
Thank you, Barry.
Can you give me one item of clothing?
Uh.
Ascot.
Can you give me one activity, please?
Oh, an activity?
Like, like, like, hmm.
What's an act?
Like, what separates an activity from a verb?
That's a great question.
Um, something like, um, tennis or like um interpretive dance
interpretive dance okay yeah okay perfect right you guys
distract chat while i get these in here i'll play the little
in my head i'm playing the loading music what kind of snacks
do you have minto i got cheeses but the extra toasty can Oh,
we those ones are the Those are ones are... Aren't they the
best?
They're so best for that, yes They're the best I'm so glad
That's the best kind of cheesing I'm so glad that they
listened to the people And we're just like everybody wants
the toasty bits Yeah, that sounds great Oh, they're so happy
Oh, I'm making me crave it too I have a I have a chicken
stick that I have taken one bite out of them and and a box
of Trader Joe's maple leaf cookies that I've eaten one
cookie out of.
I love maple leaf cookies!
That's what I wanted to that one time when we were doing the
snack try.
My Trader Joe's haul that I left in America on accident had
these cookies in it so I wanted Vicky to have some and have
you to have some.
They're my favorite oh so sorry give me a number as well
Phoebe so sorry I forgot that one does the number have to be
above or below a certain amount no anything you want
anything you want okay I'm gonna have one cookie she said
it's so fast you guys so fast yeah there's no hesitation
whatsoever okay 67 which we are above that And you guys,
Steiner will be skydiving.
I'm just a brave Steiner.
We haven't volunteered to skydive.
You guys are going to see, but this is like crazy.
This is crazy.
Guys, we have the same brain.
I think we must have the same brain.
So I think you guys just like know what I'm thinking at all
times.
No, guys, guys, it's actually crazy.
I'm so excited.
Me too.
Let's see.
I'm looking through some of the stretch goals that some
people have put in.
The script is ready.
The script is ready?
Oh, okay.
Yeah.
I got it.
All right.
Yeah, this one might be a bit shorter.
No, it's okay.
Oh, wait.
One second.
He wants to do the narration this time.
I could do it if you want it.
Yeah, I think it's funny if you guys do it because I know
what's coming.
Okay, okay.
Alright, let me pause the music.
Here we go.
Our Madlibs, Densatsu Madlibs, number two.
Okay.
The three girls made their way to Lord Loiter's Bootylicious
Layer.
concealed in the mountains of Aindona Ikebukuro.
First, they had to find a way to get inside.
The first floor is guarded by squonks, so stay vigilant.
Once we get inside, too, the floor is made of glue!
How will we get through it?
I heard there's a bolt, but we need to steer towards the
elevator using nothing but the orbs.
It'll be...
It'll be tough, but we can do it.
Somehow, using their training in interpretive dance, they
were able to trick the squawks long enough to reach the end
of the river of glue.
It was then that the girls were presented with three
buttons.
Okay, so this one says if we press it, then 67 shimmy and
Fresno nightcrawlers will suddenly come charging at us.
This sounds like Phoebe's lighter.
Because, yeah!
Well, that doesn't sound good.
If we press this one, then Fujikaze will teleport here
immediately and chase us.
Phoebe Bray wants that.
Yeah, this is Phoebe's layer.
By this point, the glue had turned to a solid sausage and is
hurtling towards them.
Quick!
Just try button three!
This sends them down a trapdoor into a secret room.
Who would be there but Lord Loider about to remove the mask?
Oh.
Anyone can be Lord Loider.
I'll be Lord Loider.
Yeah.
I'm giving up the life of petty loitering and hanging up my
ascot.
Time for you guys to find out who I really am.
As the mask slowly lowers everyone Gasps daintily the
identity is revealed to be What?
None other than Steiner.
I was
like, no.
No way.
That's crazy.
Oh my gosh.
You did a really good job not reacting to the answers that
fit perfectly.
Oh, thank you.
Thank you.
Holy moly.
It's so funny.
Oh, I get it.
Steiner put all those buttons to distract me so I can never
find find him.
Yeah.
I guess that's what it is.
For us tonight, Carly.
We enjoyed in the mountains of I'm Donut in here.
Specifically Ike Bukuro, which famously has no mountains.
And he was spitefully concealed too for some reason.
I think just Fujikaze teleporting and immediately chasing
us.
These were amazing, Vicky.
Thank you.
Glad you liked them.
Glad you liked these totally canon MVP stories from Akiba.
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
Oh, wonderful.
That was great.
That was something.
Oh, my gosh.
Well, thank you, guys.
So we re-re-re-re-re- them so nicely and we're pretty much
perfect on on time i think actually to move into our last
section if we're ready for that if you guys have stuff ready
for it yeah well let me open it i'm gonna i'm gonna switch
to our loading screen again so i can set up and then we will
play we will play all right yeah be right back then you've
got are we leaving audio oh no no they won't We are back!
Yeah!
Ooh!
Huge wiki, teeny tiny fevery!
Yeah!
And then can you like put the mirror up so they can see what
you look like too?
This is me.
I'm so massive compared to you guys.
Accurate.
I'm a flat bear.
So cute.
Yay!
So cute!
Welcome to my humble Otaku Abode, everybody.
Oh, it's lovely.
Thank you.
What do we have here?
Is this where you keep the most sugoi of games like Disguaya
and Persona?
Absolutely.
And I have, I have, I have, wait, is she?
It's meo.
What's this unity scene you've got here?
I think that's what you've got here.
Yeah.
I've got kimono friends and I have, uh, Kan-Kole- Oh, yeah.
Oh cute!
Pankole Mio, yeah.
You're cute.
This is where all the dojin-shi are.
Let's see what we got here.
Don't look at there.
You guys, how about we go outside.
See the door handle?
You can go outside.
Do I click the door?
Yes, click the door handle.
Oh, go outside.
Welcome!
We're in Akihabara!
Gosh, wow!
Wow!
oh is it like accurate it's pretty accurate part of us yeah
wow that's so fun well maybe not anymore some things are
different we're together in japan again right wait phoebe
where did you go oh yours just so swole i can't see you oh
my big capybara belly did we go to the do they think they
have the places where we filmed bernon might do actually
yeah right here was one of the places actually literally
like in this very spot was where we were running back of
course yeah it's right here yeah we let's do it again wait i
wonder if i can uh let's see yeah right shoulder here oh
yeah which which way will we we're running this way about
this way yeah we run back oh yeah
Do the rap.
Do the rap, Vicky.
Oh, um...
Oh, no.
This way, I'm riding, turning pain to power.
I feel like it wasn't even that long ago, but it feels so
nostalgic and...
I know, right?
So nice.
I can't wait till the next time we can be here in person
together.
Yeah, me too.
Oh, can we try and find the place where we did the, like,
the bit on the really busy bit where we had to, like, wait
for everyone to go away?
Where was that?
That was on, like, the main street, wasn't it?
Oh, I think it was...
You know, they were electric town.
Oh, yeah, that was over here, but I wonder if...
Oh, the map doesn't let us go, though, sadly.
Oh, now, no.
I do wonder.
Yeah.
I think it was over there somewhere.
What does this say?
Oh.
A new arcade!
Whoa!
Welcome to the arcade!
Oh dear stage!
Mega tournament.
It's got the old shutter art!
The old shutter!
Yeah!
Yeah, thank you, Konkale Mio.
She's so cool.
Those are tasty looking food things.
Wow.
Oh, it's so nice.
Yeah.
Oh, comics.
Oh, this looks tasty.
The...
What happens if you get...
It was like saying you could get in the car.
Oh, go to next area.
Wait, there's another area?
Yeah, I think if you get in the car, I think it takes you
somewhere else.
Oh, yeah.
Let's go.
Should we get in the car?
Oh, here we go.
Oh, my God.
Yay!
Oh, so cool.
Oh.
Oh, bento?
Oh, how did it go?
Gosh, it's Sega!
It's still Sega!
Oh, it's still Sega!
Where we...
Where we did the electric town part was like right over like
kind of in here.
Oh, was it?
I thought it was over here.
Oh, you're right, you're right.
Yes, you are right.
I think it was over this way.
I got turned around.
I think it was like... I think it was like right on this
corner right actually.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, I remember.
yeah wow i think it was right here and we were like wait
wait wait okay now go electric town the ads are so good oh
yeah because i remember we wanted to go back to like try and
capture the train going in the back too but we kind of
couldn't yeah right yeah because we were right by the train
as the train track it was exactly this place right here oh
oh melon books oh we going in i don't think we can can we go
oh can we not oh sad i want to go in these ads are so fun
though wow caroquet pasera and everything oh caroquet pasera
if you've never been to akiba before you guys this is like
it's it's kind of old version but it's still very accurate
this is so accurate a few things on there now they're like
the sega arcade and stuff but um what did the sega arcade
become it's well it turned to giggle and now it's top hat or
silk hat or whatever silk cat oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
they they they made it not red anymore oh my gosh oh
Oh, what is the song?
Do you guys recognize it?
I don't know what you mean.
I recognize it, but I don't know what it is.
I don't know.
I've definitely heard it before.
I was like, hey, I don't even know who it's by.
But I recognize it.
Yeah.
Well, you can keep walking for quite a long time, actually.
Can you?
Yeah, right?
Yeah.
I'm following.
Oh, there's an Itasha over here.
Whoa!
Cool!
What kind of Itasha?
Soft map.
Oh, we can't go over to the Itasha, but there's an Itasha
over there.
I'm coming to see.
Whoa, I'm trying to see what it is.
Cafe Coco was even here.
Oh my gosh.
I've got everything.
Oh, there's a Itasha.
Yeah.
Can we go that side?
I want to see what it is.
I can't tell.
I wonder.
I mean, we can, um...
see back there i wonder if we can oh yeah even somewhere
else like by the station or something maybe oh oh there we
go can you guys tell what it is who it is uh levia levia
from what i'm like zooming my eyes in but i'm not sure yeah
it looks pretty cool though i like the blue tires very cool
yeah is the mr donut still there oh no i imagine it probably
it would be over there let me in let me in let me in let me
go go i want go i think i see it gogo or a cocoa so depends
on my mood i think in general i prefer the curry sauce at
gogo actually yeah i think it's tasty but i like i like i
need to try it then and i've had so much well i think the
good thing about coco ichiban is that like it's got so much
variation of like toppings so that's really good um because
gogo's just like not very much variation but the curry sauce
is really nice at gogo yeah i i typically like to make my
own curry because i like it sweeter ah you put like honey in
it yeah put apples in mine oh that's so nice i've always
wondered like i like to ask people do you like to sweeten
your curry with honey apples or chocolate i've never try
chocolate i make this special um it's like my mom's recipe
every holiday season has bananas people think that's weird
but it's pretty good it sounds interesting i would try that
oh i think this taxi goes to the station maybe it looks like
it's going that direction let's try it yeah because i don't
think we can go any further down here right can we oh maybe
we can't oh it does oh wait can we i know yeah i think i
think the taxi goes that way maybe no we can't go any
further Oh my gosh.
Wait, this is so old.
Wait, this is where we filmed the other bit, Janai.
Yeah.
We're walking down there.
We're walking down right in front of...
Yeah.
Right in front of this iconic, this building with the tubes.
Oh, Momo and Doke.
Yay.
Yeah, this is a very...
This is...
Oh my gosh.
Wow.
This is like now...
This whole building is like now a hotel.
this is a whole bunch of shops and stuff in here wow wow hey
guys you want to do your do you want to do your sassy walk
like in the like in the video yeah yeah yeah yeah i don't
have my megaphone unfortunately but i'll try and do it okay
we're watching oh yeah totally accurate totally accurate.
Your turn, Phoebe.
Protect the watershed, we require sacrifice.
See, I'm so cute.
I can't make it sassy.
So cute.
You know, I think, you know, it's just not complete without
you in the Vegeta outfit, I'll be honest.
Oh, I should have found, like, a Vegeta avatar or something.
Yeah.
Wait, this is so cool, though.
You can go to these places.
Oh, can you go in the station?
Oh, can you?
Ah, yes.
You are my favorite, my favorite rail company.
You are.
Wait, can we go to the other side too?
Wow.
Oh, my gosh.
It's still the AKB48.
Oh, my God.
We can portal to Night, Akiba.
Let's go have a look at this.
Oh, no.
Let's go look at this, guys.
The bakery, the fateful bakery where we needed to get kicked
out.
Remember?
Ah, yes.
The one where we were laughing at those guys were laughing
so loud And they were like, please be quiet This is where we
learned that Steiner used to eat bugs I always said the
president Where he used to eat bugs Against each other And
then what would he eat Either the loser as a punishment Or
the winner to absorb their power Which one?
I think he ate the winner to absorb their power is what he
said And we laughed so loudly By accident guys by accident
that we had to be told please be a bit quieter and we're
like oh no yeah even though there were some guys before us
that were so loud oh and they were having a so yeah they're
having a weird conversation such a weird conversation yeah
oh my gosh there was yeah it is still akb yeah oh and the
beaks coffee that's so funny wow wow and the Wow, this is so
nostalgic.
Oh, sorry, AKW.
AK, so sorry, AKW.
What'd you say?
You can't actually see it here, but it's always been my
dream for us to be on the screen that would be here, but
it's actually not there.
Oh, the UDX one.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I would, I would, I would want that.
One day.
One day, one day, one day.
Sorry, I just realized something.
I'm so sorry.
I don't know, boo.
Uh...
Do you need to be right back?
I went to the wrong gaming screen.
Uh, one second, one second guys.
Oh...
Wait, ah!
I did- I set up everything wrong!
Oh, one second, guys.
Oh, shoot.
Uh, sorry, sorry, sorry.
Oh, take your time, take your time.
You need to go to loading screen.
It's totally fine.
No, it's okay.
I just realized I set up my actual gaming setup instead of
the hope for the day one.
So, like, the thing, the fundraising thing hasn't been
there.
I'm so sorry.
Oh, don't worry.
Don't worry.
You've been doing so much to run the stream today.
Thank you so much.
There's been so many things to switch between.
Oh, good.
I'm sorry, guys.
And also, it wasn't that long.
It's your time.
Yeah.
Oh, you're so small and sweet.
This is literally how I see you in real life.
Oh, am I your baby Chino?
Oh, you're my baby Chino.
Oh, it's so sweet.
Oh, it's so cute.
I wish I could hog slash hog yeah I wish I could hog yeah I
wonder how do you emo with this oh I it's if you are
expressions oh what happened what was that I back flipped
and I don't think the oh wow oh cool yeah I don't think the
capybara has any that's unfortunate I'm sorry no I have a uh
santa hat cute santa
well it's only one three months wait i can't stop wiggling
oh geez wiggle wiggle wiggle wiggle yeah guys take a look at
this inside the station they had this cool teleport that
lets you go to nighttime ishara look this is great if you
want to do like this area is really fun if you want to do
like a vr chat stream too because it's a really good area
wait we could do like uh oh it's just just just balling
ideas we could do like an akiba street live but i keep a
street live well we do have our 3d of our vr chat stream
that we have to redeem now so that can be so cool would you
guys want a street live and akiba oh my god that would be so
cute i think yeah it'll be so fun wow look at this wow
What's going on?
Nighttime.
This is Akiba?
What's going on?
Are we sure?
Is it?
Are we in Shibuya?
Where are we?
Wait, where are you guys?
Where are you?
All these people are doing like the Michael Jackson lean.
Yeah, okay.
Let's go back to Akiba Hover.
I have no idea what's going on here.
Oh, wait.
Wait, I think I know what's happening here.
Oh, okay.
Different instances?
Yeah, I think so.
No idea what this is.
Yeah, don't worry.
We could go back to the main home room.
Oh, sorry, guys.
I thought it was nighttime, Akihabura.
No, it's okay.
I know it.
I thought it was, too, right?
It's not.
I have no idea what it is.
It's either some kind of party or something.
I think we're at the Shibuya Crossing, no?
Yeah, I don't know what's going on.
What happened?
Yeah.
Yeah, don't worry.
We could just go back to home and try another world, maybe.
Okay, do you guys have a world that you want to...
Since we started with mine...
Go ahead, Phoebe.
You've used, like, VRChat quite a lot before, right?
I'm going to quit out of this video.
Yeah, Phoebe.
Lately, but let's see what I have.
Worlds.
I've got favorite, summer favorite.
Yeah, if you just create it, like, as a private instance.
And then, like, you can do new instance and then private,
like, invite plus or whatever.
And then you can invite us.
Okay.
Yeah.
New instance.
Oh, the police are here.
Yeah, I have no idea what...
Yeah, I have no...
What is going on in this world that you're in?
Oh, what is...
Oh, yeah, wait, it's definitely Shibuya because it says
Shibuya Mark City in the background.
Yeah, yeah, it's definitely Shibuya, but so strange.
What is going on?
Yeah, I'm going back to the home menu.
No idea what's going on.
Alright.
What are you thinking, Fimi, for our next adventure?
I've got it.
It's initializing world.
And then I'm gonna invite you guys and I'll surprise you.
I'm so excited.
Send invite.
Minto, what are you looking up on?
Quit peeking.
You know you're still on stream, right?
Yeah!
Can you invite us in?
Wait, this is different.
Can you get the invite?
Yeah, I did.
Thank you.
Wait,
I want to go there.
I'm going.
Yeah.
I'm terrifying.
I'm busy dreams.
Bam, bam, bam.
I like the other one better, but I don't remember what it
was called, guys.
i'm gonna i'm gonna need a list of recommended worlds guys
of that kind of the the soul you know the soul variety okay
okay i'm
excited for this one wow it's like we're going to disney
again oh i'm sorry that we didn't get to spend too much time
at tokyo disney we ended up going It was kind of late
because of my work and stuff.
It was so fun.
Oh, joining.
I'm finally, I'm going in.
I'm entering.
I wonder how to hold on.
Oh, and I guess there's a door that will take you to the
magic kingdom.
Oh my god!
Hi!
Look at the page!
Mine's still loading.
It took me a long time.
Ah, okay.
Oh!
Wow!
Outfits and stuff.
Oh my gosh, it's my guy.
Is that your guy?
Make a while.
Where's Judy?
Yeah, where is Judy?
Good question.
I love the outfits down here as well.
Are these Kingdom Hearts models here?
They have the...
I'm trying to work it out.
Yeah, I don't know.
It's like not Sora.
Oh, wait, there's a Buzz and Woody on the very top.
If you look up.
Oh, that's cute.
Yeah, that's very cute.
I think we can use these doors to go to the magic kingdom.
Let's go!
Oh.
How do we get inside?
This is the actual Disney, right?
The horror VR thing.
Yeah, what is...
This is not so kind of like creepy pastas.
We're back 2021!
I think we're going over here, right?
Oh, wait, hold on.
I'm gonna turn off the music.
Okay, we're good.
Oh, excellent.
Let go of my...
Oh, that's pretty pretty.
Oh, you
little.
Oh, look at those fireworks, you guys.
So it's just like the park after hours open, especially for
us.
Yeah, just for dance for us.
Wait, where does this go to?
What is that?
Oh, oh, oh, whoa.
You go?
Yeah, how do I leave?
I don't know.
Do you want us to follow you?
We'll follow you.
Oh, oh my God.
Okay, I'm coming too.
I'm coming too.
Oh, what happened?
Oh, my God.
Are we in like Steamboat Willie or something?
Oh, there it is.
There's the boat!
Yeah!
Oh, it won't let us get on.
That's so lame.
Oh.
Where are you?
Goofy, go swimming!
Doofy, are you good?
Wait, did you pick up Goofy?
Yeah, you could pick him up.
Wait, where did everybody go?
We just started throwing him off.
What is this?
How do we get out of here?
Here, here, here.
Return home.
Okay, we just click here?
Yeah.
Oh, nice, we're back.
Ah.
Return home.
Okay, nice.
Okay!
Wow!
Oh my gosh, there's Thunder Mountain and there's a...
Which Disney lives has been to be?
I think this is California, no?
California.
Okay.
Oh, the music is back!
Here, I'll just turn it off.
Okay.
I'm so sorry, I didn't think about this.
No, it's okay!
We're good.
Okay, okay.
La la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la.
Wow.
There it is.
Mr. Walter Disney himself.
Honestly, like theme parks with you guys is like one of my
favorite MVP activities.
I love that fan club art of us at the theme park.
It was so like accurate, right?
Me too.
The one does go dead.
Minto is so like organized.
Yeah.
Minto is so organized with the like, you know, we're going
here, we're going to this ride, that ride and then we're
doing this then i'm just eating and phoebe is just like
having a great time you know we can go to neverland too oh
where where's that do you want to go to neverland i don't
know i'm scared there's portals everywhere we can go
wherever we please i guess wow is there part of the park
that you would want to go to if we were there actually i i
don't know um i wonder if any of the roller Yeah, maybe I
enter it and it does like a little roller coaster animation
or something.
I wonder.
The space mountain is...
Lead the way.
Okay.
Yeah, lead the way.
Well, maybe I wonder if it's like this, this little portal
here, right?
It doesn't have a name, so I'm guessing it's Space Mountain.
Oh, all right.
Let's try it.
Oh, we're in space?
Whoa.
Like actual space.
Oh, wow.
Okay.
Wait, uh, wow.
Space.
Whoa.
Wow.
Space.
Wait, is there anything here?
I don't think so.
I think it's just for the aesthetics.
Oh, but it's pretty though.
Look at all the planets and the stars.
Wow, we're zooming through space.
Wow.
Look, I watched Project.
Well, hello.
Uh, what was it?
Ryan Gosling.
Project Hail Mary!
I still need to see it.
it i still need to see it i'm so excited yeah i haven't seen
it yet i'm excited so good you liked it feby yes also oh no
nothing i say i like vicky should just go into it blind yes
yes go in blind go in blind talk later okay or we'll talk
what you watch we'll talk what you talk what you watched
okay i'll try and watch it asap all right how do we go back
i'm back home i'm press the Oh no, there we go.
I have to get it at the right angle for me to give me the
buttons.
Oh, but it takes us to like this far away from the castle.
Oh, now, hold on now.
I feel like it should, yeah, take you to the portal where
you were just in.
Right.
Yeah.
I mean, it's a really, really, really cool recreation.
It's really cool, yeah.
It is cool.
So cool.
Aw, the fireworks are so pretty.
You need to turn the music off again.
Oh, we are!
We're good, we're good.
Okay.
Here, maybe I can take you to a place that is not, you know,
with copyright music.
I can take you to a place too.
Oh, sure, yeah.
Should we talk?
I'll go back to the home menu then.
You can invite me.
No, no, it's okay.
You don't have to leave.
I can do it right here.
I did by accident.
I'm sorry.
Oh.
Go mend a sigh.
That's okay.
I'm such a VR chat noob.
No, it's okay.
Yeah, I'll drop a portal.
What?
new instance drop portal audio jungle audio jungle there you
go thank you oh bring me there once I load in I'm taking you
in let's see how this goes not the so good mid world you
guys but I want to okay invite I...
Oh gosh, how do you do it again?
Phoebe, can you invite her too?
Yeah, let me see.
That might be better, yeah.
Oh, wait, no.
No?
I don't have permission to invite users to this instance.
What?
No, I did...
Oh, wait, there it is.
Social.
I got her.
Uh-uh.
Send that back.
Thank you.
I have received.
I am coming.
Wow.
so accurate it's crazy oh all right
what is this dude can we hit stuff oh oh good oh i see you
guys up there hello oh my gosh hello do you see me how do
you get down there i don't yeah well did you do that yeah it
was the gold thing it was the gold thing oh oh or like run
into it oh see
I forgot actually how bare bones this world is.
I think I made a mistake.
Are there pigs in here?
Are there cows?
You know, all them cool animals?
Maybe there's creatures.
Maybe we're the creatures.
We're the creatures.
We're the creatures in Minecraft.
Whoa.
I actually...
I don't remember.
It looks so accurate.
I know, right?
Like, even, like, the little highlights on each block.
That's crazy.
Guys, I'm afraid there's nothing here.
Oh, I see.
Oh, wait.
I'm digging down.
You can dig down?
Look up.
I mean, look at me.
We're digging.
How far can we go?
I hit bedrock.
Oh.
Yeah, I don't think we can go any further than this.
It teleported me back home.
Why did it teleport you back home?
I don't know.
Oh.
Oh, it's okay.
Come grab us for a new world.
It's fine.
bb but did you have a world that you wanted to take
everybody to um a lot of my worlds are there purely for
aesthetic i will take you guys to uh
this one maybe i'm sorry they don't have any recommends i'm
very much a we are chat noob no don't worry about it it'll
be fun for us to do more of this together yeah i'm excited
we'll find some fun ones for our for our 3D VR chat stream.
I'm so excited!
Here, I'll invite you guys to this one.
Thank you!
I think I liked this one.
Okay!
I have not touched VR chat in a very, very long time.
Luna Ascension?
This sounds fun.
Is this Spacey?
Oh!
No diamonds.
Wow, looks pretty.
Yeah, it does.
Pink and green and blue from the looks of it.
And purple.
Oh, it's pretty.
Wow.
Whoa.
Hi, you guys.
Where should we go up this way?
Mm-hmm.
Oh.
Wow.
Wow!
Oh!
Imagine this in VR.
This looks like a setting for a Fujikaze video.
I don't know.
All the nature.
I could see it.
Yeah.
What's it?
I love this.
Wow.
This is so calming.
I used to just like coming to places like this and just
sitting here.
Yeah.
Yeah, I get it.
I get it.
Nice, relaxing way to sort of like ground yourself in a
place like this, you know?
Nice.
It's so pretty.
Oh, I love the butterflies.
I tried to see the moon.
There we go.
Can I sit on the swing?
Yeah, can you sit on the swing?
I tried.
It wouldn't let me.
Vicky might be the only one tall enough to look like I'm
sitting on it.
Ish.
I guess.
That looks so good.
Oh, what is this?
What's that?
Oh, what is the drawing tablet?
Wow!
Oh, is that the concept?
Did somebody like draw this and then this is their art?
Oh, that's so nice.
Oh, wow.
Is that what it is?
It's magical.
Artists' imagination.
It's so magical.
It definitely looks like something out of a dream or
something, doesn't it?
The heart.
Yeah.
of place friends make promises at i love that it's so nice
oh it is like that's a really really romantic way of
thinking about it it is what about hmm okay let's see i'm
gonna drop a portal okay the portal's too close to a user
okay there oops there you go here let's go oh starry home
starry home
Oh, so many pretty places.
I can take you guys to Metal Gear 2.
Why?
We can go to Metal Gear.
Okay, I'll take you after this one.
Yeah.
Guys, we are at...
It'll be a preview for when we play it.
We've hit...
We hit over 80,000 dollars.
Over 80,000!
Thank you.
Oh, you guys.
kill oh this is gonna be yeah it's gonna mean so much for
hope for the day and all the wonderful work that they do for
mental health awareness and suicide prevention so thank you
so much thank you so much denji thank you thank you thank
you oh yeah i love going to these ones in vr like it's so
nice yeah there's a Yudu Camp VR game on Steam.
Yeah, and it's not really a game.
You just kind of like sit with the girls like on the lake
and everything and just hang out.
It's so nice.
We could go camping in VR.
Yes.
Oh, oh.
Dan Setsu camping ship.
I've never been camping.
Wait, Vicky, this is perfect for you.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Oh, whoa, whoa.
The Capybara.
Wait, where's the Capybara?
No, you.
You were the Capybara.
oh in the onsen oh i see i see i see what you're saying oh
yeah you can like oh yeah i have a capybara aren't i yes i
forgot oh wait a second capybara is in the onsen with the
little yuzu on my head oh yeah that's a camping trip would
be so fun that'd be so fun we could go camping near mount
fuji or something yes yes yes yes yes yes that sounds lovely
but you can put like a I like how you're just like
completely submerged under the water.
I know.
Oh, you're like the perfect height, Minto.
Minto, you're like the perfect height, yeah.
Oh, are we watching Burn On?
My favorite music video?
Oh.
Wow.
Oh, that's so cool.
You've played videos.
Eh.
Whoa.
So cool.
Don't worry.
I'm not drowning.
I promise.
Just, you can hold your breath.
real long one of those people like to be fair you do train
to do that as a as a voice actor so true you know yeah wow
wow this is nice yeah this is so relaxing and tuna oh look
at the view too oh man i'm like i love the sea i love just
going out to the sea i wish i could just go swimming This is
so nice.
Wow!
I wonder if you can jump.
Oh no!
No!
Um...
I'm stuck.
You're stuck?
Okay, we might need to reload the world.
Oh, shoot.
Oh, hi.
Hello.
Hi.
Oh, you can respawn.
There's a respawn button if you...
Can you go swimming?
Wait, okay.
I'll join you guys in the sea.
Oh, I think the fast travel is...
Oh, fast travel.
Yeah?
Oh.
How did you guys get out of the sea?
Sorry, I went to come see you guys in the sea.
Oh, press escape, and then there's a respawn button.
Respawn.
Okay, nice.
Thank you.
And then click fast travel.
Yeah.
Fast travel.
Bum, bum, bum, bum.
I don't know where that is, but I'll come find you guys.
This is so pretty.
Wow.
Oh, lovely.
We could go vacationing in a place like this one day.
Oh, definitely.
I would love that.
Thank you.
Yeah, we could get a little seaside little cottagey thing.
Yeah.
Oh, lovely.
So beautiful.
Oh, yeah, what's back here?
Oh, I see.
I'm checking myself out in the mirror.
Yeah, we can jump on the bed.
Jump on the bed.
Whoa.
Wee!
Ooh, bed settings, bed collider.
What does that mean?
Oh, okay, yeah, keep the collider on, actually.
Oh!
Wow, so cute!
So cute!
Pinto, did you have a world you wanted to go to next?
Oh, yeah!
I'll put one down!
Probably our last world, I think.
Okay, well then.
If I'm correct in thinking so.
Yeah, I think so.
I have one then.
Okay.
Will this be a spoiler for me?
I don't think so.
Or Phoebe.
Just in time for Steiner to explode on the screen.
Oh, nice.
Oh, I went through.
Okay.
You have to like...
I'm so addicted.
I need to say more.
to the sun station?
Or can we just go anywhere?
Oh, wait.
Don't go.
Actually, don't go.
Is it spoilers?
It is spoilers!
Wait, why is this the only place it allows you to go?
Okay, hold on.
I'll go to a new world and I'll invite you.
I'll go home.
Don't worry.
Yeah, I'll go back to the home, baby door.
No!
No, why?
Why?
Oh my god.
This is the worst place to take you.
Okay.
Oh my god.
Wait, oh.
Oh my god!
I'm so mad right now!
Okay, it's fine.
Uh...
Just don't look...
Everybody shields your eyes!
It's even playing the music!
Oh my gosh!
No!
What?
It said like...
It said like chill area, so I thought it would be like the
campfire.
Okay, here we go.
Um, I'll invite you guys.
Yes, please!
Maybe?
Maybe some... I wanted to end on something like a little
kind of chill and nice, but...
This is fun, too.
So, so chill.
Metal Gasol, and then we go.
This is fine.
I'm so excited.
Wow.
Whoa, is this like an exact recreation from the game?
That's so cool.
It is!
This is the very first area you enter.
planning to start a metal gear journey at some point once i
finished up a few other games so i'm excited oh hello i'm
swimming where are you guys oh is that not where we're meant
to go this way is so you crawl under here you crawl yeah and
there will be guys walking around here and they'll be like
oh no what was that sound and you're going around you're
like oh oh there's get over there oh baby baby baby here
baby oh there you go oh yeah nice yeah okay yeah look out
for any any guys about yeah all right get in the elevator
get in the elevator all right i'm in i'm in oh wait does it
go anywhere else that's it oh that's it oh I thought it
might take us in the second area.
It doesn't.
Still cool, though.
Yeah, every creation is really cool.
I wonder if we can swim through the water and go somewhere.
I wonder.
Maybe we can.
Oh, maybe.
Oh, no.
No, it does not appear so.
It's not reinventing that.
Oh.
Cool, though.
Oh, where did you go?
I'm here.
Hey, was there something?
No.
The edge of the world.
Oh.
Yeah, the edge of the world.
Aw.
Wow.
Let me see if I have something, though.
We can end on something.
Something kind of nice.
Yeah, finale.
Yeah, I have something.
I have something.
Ooh.
Somewhere pretty where we can thank everybody.
Yes, of course.
Oh, I'll put the portal down there.
All right.
Here we go.
Oh, this one looks pretty.
I don't remember this one, but it looks pretty.
I have it saved, so I must have liked it at some point.
Wow.
Yeah.
So pretty.
It looks nice.
Wow.
Oh, music.
Okay.
I got rid of it.
We're good.
I wonder if I can put on something else You can probably
turn the video off if you want Oh yeah, there we go, there
we go Yeah We can just look out this way Aww Wow So pretty
Oh, well, thank you so much Then she Yes, thank you,
everybody Draw Draw Oh, wow Wow Oh, I didn't mean to Thank
you Oh wow, wait, where's the pens?
Oh wow They're on the wall They're on the wall, yeah Oh, I'm
too short for this Thank you Oh, thank you How do you get it
to like line up Or am I just being...
No, it's kind of, yeah Thank you I tried to write thank you
but I have no idea what I actually wrote no okay Oh I wrote
it pink green and blue oh you did such a good job wow yeah
wow how did you do that wait it was fast to do it okay I'm
gonna try again Dan She Mmm Fat I think it's as far as
you're going to get guys with mine.
I'm sorry But thank you very much.
Yeah, thank you so much everybody.
Thank you.
Thank you, thank you.
An amazing, amazing amount raised.
I'm just going to go to a an amazing cause.
You know, I think, you know, all three of us is a really
important cause.
I think, yeah.
And particularly for me, I don't know, like, I'm sure
everyone has like, you know, personal anecdotes.
and stuff but i think i just i'm really proud that we were
able to raise so much money for such a fantastic cause so
yeah you know i i'm just i'm very grateful to you guys and
thank you thank you so much you guys have been really really
happy your first fundraiser got to be with hope for the day
as well well definitely you know keep doing our best to
support the causes that we believe in in yeah you guys have
been so much more than generous and you know we'll we'll i'm
looking forward to delivering all of their incentives as
well so i hope you guys look forward to those too and um
we'll have all the stuff all like the things finalized so uh
uh as i mean as soon as we can get them done because yeah we
obviously didn't have them done because we weren't sure if
we how much we would aim get to but you guys like totally
blew all of our expectations out of the out of the water so
amazing absolutely amazing thank you guys so so so much for
yes thank you all of it yeah and it's gonna really it's
gonna really help people you know and and just so proud of
this community yeah yeah and remember remember you're not
alone and there's nothing wrong with feeling a little.
Mint had a really good word for it earlier.
It's not wiggly.
It was squiggly or something.
I don't know.
Yeah.
It's totally okay to feel wavy sometimes.
And it's a way to feel wavy a lot of the time, actually.
But you're not alone.
There's lots of other waves out there in the ocean with you.
And there's always options for how you can care for.
and be gentle with yourself so yeah yes very well put yeah
how appropriate to end on this wavy aquarium as well yeah
there's a beautiful there's a funny enough there's an animal
crossing quote that i really like by the character katrina
and she says remember that bad times are just times that are
bad and you know there are good times too and you know
emotionally wavy can be you know your low points are low but
the high points can be high and you know but through all of
it we'll be supporting you guys we're always rooting for
your happiness and your success and everything good to um
happen to you all and um you know whether whether you um are
are graduating school or trying to find a new job you know
we'll be streaming through it all and we'll help you out if
you need a little pick me up through uh through your day so
thank you guys so much thank you so much truly truly all
righty wow what a special stream it's been guys hey yeah
really special yeah thank for being here with us yeah we
appreciate so much we are really excited to see some of you
at moshi oh yes yes yes i'm excited lots of exciting things
to look forward to in the future yeah maybe another little
another little secret something as well maybe tomorrow maybe
You guys look forward to the eventual 3D concert that will
be on the Densetsu channel so...
Yeah!
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Thank you so much you guys!
Thank you, thank you!
Then she...
You later!
Later!
Bye bye everyone, bye bye!
Thank you!